good morning welcome to the division one
of finance
as the acting chair of division one of
the house finance committee i find that
due to the state of emergency declared
by the governor as a result of covet 19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to meet electronically this is a work
session pertaining to division budget
matters please note that there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporary contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website
the notice of this meeting
complies with house rule
house rules and rsa 91-8 anyone who has
a problem accessing this meeting should
email
lba underscore fiscal at
ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
lba staff are on the meeting assisting
us
please note that all votes are to be
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence please also state whether
there is anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
uh my name is
tracy emrick and i am in the
finance meeting room
good morning is we're representative
tiberos i'm in the meeting room on
lob202
[Music]
gerald griffin
in the meeting room
202.
yes i'm representative mary beth walls
i'm in my home there is my daughter and
my husband are elsewhere in the house
okay
and i think we're ready to begin
dr o'neill excuse me chairman emma i
just have a question and that is i'm
having a hard time finding where we got
the documents from the office of the
child advocate were they sent to us
because they're not on the lba website i
i think they will be
they were we were having a little bit of
electronic issues
uh to get started this morning and i
think mike just went back over and he's
he'll get the docs posted
thank you it's just i
we've gotten so many i was afraid i got
them and couldn't find them that's why i
was asking well i can hold them up but i
don't think you can see what they look
like i don't think that's going to work
either but thank you that's very
thoughtful
it does have a color letterhead so that
might be helpful
well i look forward to them being posted
i'll keep that up and refresh it thank
you okay
dr o'neill welcome and the floor is
yours if you'd like to discuss
good morning good morning mr chair and
thank you all for having us today um i'm
moira o'neil the the child advocate i
have with me karen kimmel who's our
program
manager and and is our expert on our
budget um um representative walter would
you like us to email you quickly a
document would that be helpful
karen can you say one i would love that
sure
email i'll have it right away okay
perfect can you send it to my attention
and i'll make sure that it gets
okay do you have all the emails karen
well i'll give you it's m-b-w-a-l-z
at the regular legislative right thank
you
um so while that's going i'll i'll get
started in the interest of time um and
you you did get the document thank you
very much for sending the questions that
you sent it helped us prepare for this
um for this discussion this morning um
the office of the child advocate which
was established
in in the legislature in 2017 it came
into being in 2018 is actually new again
this year and september 18th in 2020
rsa21v went into effect and so that
considerably expanded the office's
jurisdiction and mandate so we're sort
of starting fresh again
we now have responsibility for oversight
of all children's services provided by
or through arrangement of state
executive agencies so that includes but
isn't limited to child protection
juvenile justice behavioral health
developmental disabilities early
supports and education as well
we meet this mandate
essentially through four main roles
first we review children's services and
care and that includes
reviewing receiving complaints about
services working with the agencies
involved to resolve the complaints we
visit children in care when we're not in
lockdown from a pandemic we do visit
children remotely as well and assist
them when they need it and we review and
monitor critical incidents that happen
involving children who are in state care
we also review and collaborate on
program of policy developments
this is all by statute and that includes
participating in many committees working
groups and advisory panels and providing
input for system improvements
the third role that we have is to
regularly consult
with and advise the governor the
legislators the agencies and
public systems in the interests of
children right now is a very busy time
we've been consulting and helping craft
legislation to serve children
and then the fourth role that we have is
providing outreach and education on
state systems and that includes
providing children and other
constituents with information about how
the state operates referring them to
services
assisting with system navigation
and disseminating research findings and
practice standards we use the office as
a platform to make sure everyone is
informed about what children need
so in in our
2020 annual report
just to give you a sense of the workload
of the past year before the statute
changed we saw 312 individual
constituent complaints about children
receiving services or not
we managed
2183 critical incidents we reviewed and
those included 18 child deaths
we do intensive critical incident
summaries we did 10 of those last year
we did 14 individual child case reviews
that helped teams manage make good
decisions about
how children were being cared for we
have a very interesting process to
review system issues
with a science a safety science based
instrument that engages
not only looks at the system but also
engages
the people who work in the system so
that they can solve their own
and there's another long list of other
things that we do i don't want to take
too much time on that but i'm happy to
answer questions about it so looking
forward
to the next biennium
we're already seeing um a great growth
in in our role as people start to
understand our oversight and where we're
helpful
um the currency of the office of the
child advocate is access to information
so when we're brought in to um help with
system questions um and create whether
it's creating new programs or evaluating
existing ones
we're able to have a very special view
of things because we have this access to
information about children all of their
records
and be able to find out how kids are
doing in the system
and that's really informative and we're
able to keep things confidential but
also inform the process so
we've been very very busy we were hit
hard by the covid pandemic this year in
terms of staff availability off and on
and we've still been a mighty little
agency getting a lot accomplished
so we you have before you
the governor's recommended budget which
is 670 thousand dollars in the first
year and 691 in the second um we have
outlined priorities um that were in our
original um submission and also a couple
of things we've rediscovered since then
so that our budget that we're asking for
is
between 816 and 854 in the first year
and 862
in the second year
and why there's a range is that we
discovered a new need in terms of
a case management system and database
that we haven't purchased so we don't
have the final cost of that
but we're looking at a couple of
different systems so that may change
over there so i'm going to stop there
and take questions if you have questions
about individual items or if you want me
to explain a bit more about the
difference between the governor's budget
and our requested budget
i think i would i would make a comment
about the case management software
so i would i would suggest you touch
base with i
i t
because in their presentation
they said that they have
a lot of requests for case management
and that they're actually using
salesforce.com
which can be easily modified apparently
i i i'm telling you what he said i i
have no knowledge myself but you might
want to check because it could be a less
expensive way to get to the case
management solution yes thank you thank
you for that um and just to clarify
when this office opened up in 2018
we worked with doit were really generous
with us
in providing for free for three years um
the sales force platform we were
actually the pilot for it
and and what happened was because you're
when you're the pilot of a very large
enterprise
um you you
you you get what you get um and so we
were grateful for that
but what's happened is because it's such
a large enterprise everyone moved on to
the bigger agencies and we're so small
um so we haven't we went for two years
trying to make changes because in
addition to the to the to this the
software being new they also were
rolling out how to roll it out you know
they were the sort of technical pieces
of it and so when they when they rolled
out our system um it went really fast
and it didn't correct so we ended up
with a system that's not all that
useless it's very good for
um holding case documents and um and
keeping track of things
but we don't have a very um robust
reporting
ability out of it which is what we need
in order to inform people like you
um and so we had for two years running
requests to make changes so that it
would be a more workable um system
and that was delayed delayed and then of
course the pandemic happened
and and i have nothing bad to say about
doit i think that they were heroes of
the pandemic they really stepped up and
um and made this this state operate um
but what's has it's happened is that we
have three-year-old um problems with our
system um and some of them are really
like ridiculous problems and others are
really operational problems um and we
are a very unique agency and the kinds
of information we gather is very unique
and and we've discovered since that
there are a couple of software packages
that are made specifically for offices
like ours
that are really functional in um
not only gathering data but also
prompting us and how we manage our cases
making sure that we keep up with them
and then and then holding things so that
we can report out on really significant
information that informs how the system
is operating um so we have
actually been
trying to discuss this with doit um and
it's it's to a point where they're just
not available because of the pandemic um
and but before then you know we weren't
really you know it's just not a priority
and such a huge undertaking of this
whole um
uh system-wide
is
expansion that they're doing with all
the other agencies so we thought it
would be most expedient so this is the
third year so now we start to pay for
the sales force system and so what we've
done in the budget is subtracted what we
would pay doit for the sales force and
put it towards a new system
makes all the sense of the world so you
were fine as a beta but now that it's
time to roll out
[Laughter]
someone else would take the first plunge
you took all the arrows we did
a question representative
yeah uh thank you uh
dr o'neill this is uh representative uh
t belgium i have a question and please
excuse my ignorance
i'm not a parent but
what are the ages that you deal with for
child advocate i i don't know if they're
preteen or teens or what
and i apologize for my ignorance no
that's no problem thank you so much for
the question if i think that a lot of
people know about the office of the
child advocate when they have children
and more so when they have problems um
so the office of the child advocate
oversees all children's services
that the state offers or arranges so
that would include children from birth
to 18.
we do actually serve some children who
are older who are still served by the
system up to age 20 or 21 or so we
wouldn't drop them if they need and
those are children who would be
who who would be or should be served by
say child protection um who may be
involved in juvenile justice and now
with the expansion of our statute we
expect that we'll get um cases involving
education access to special education
children who need developmental
disability services and already we're
getting very very busy in the area of
mental and behavioral health you know
we're following and working hard on the
issue of children who are stuck in
emergency rooms seeking acute
psychiatric care
although yeah thank you
dr o'neal just a follow-up
in cases and i don't know what they've
reversed
you know how you handle this in cases
where teenagers due to substance abuse
or whatever
end up abusing their parents which
department actually takes care of that
thank you for the question so that's
there's there's there's a two a couple
answers for that you know if there's if
the child
has um some kind of problem that the
parents aren't attending to that could
be child protection um uh if the police
are called because the pan because the
child has assaulted the parent that's
juvenile justice both of those are under
dcyf the division for children youth and
families but that also sounds as though
the child needs behavioral health
services which would be under the
division of behavior children's
behavioral health in um dhhs so so and
that's where the office of the child
advocate can act as sort of a conduit to
make sure that all agencies are working
to make sure that that child gets their
needs met
thank you uh dr o'neill i'm glad that
it's that you were as a conduit as well
that makes things a lot easier for
everybody involved thank you
other questions from the committee
well we can look you're you're you have
an extensive budget
it's
on page 134 of our budget books
uh and it goes 134 and part way down
135.
we have other departments that come in
that have 130 pages so yes thank you for
that
this one you can catch in one one
we are a heavy lift
[Laughter]
any any questions on the budget
yes mr chairman this is representative
walls i'm not sure you can see when i
raised my hand oh sorry well that's okay
i'm not afraid to speak up
so mora
actually everybody that's coming in here
seems to be on a 15 cut of general funds
you're not your budget looks like you're
doing you actually go up in your budget
um it is you know you've said what you
need you need a new a news system you
need a car and you need a new person
but other than it looks like in all
honesty you kind of came out of this
budget process unscathed compared to
everybody else am i reading this
correctly
oh thank you for that question i i don't
think we would ever say we're unscathed
because we are so small we have such a
broad mandate but we did i believe we
made a good argument because of the
statute change and the mandate that
expanded i think the governor took that
into consideration um and allowed us to
have actually in the governor's budget
he gave us a new halftime position a
permanent halftime position um so we are
actually asking for that halftime
position we asked for that to be a
full-time position and we asked for yet
another position as well
and then the vehicle is we believe a
cost-saving measure
because we do have a great deal of
travel ahead of us
once the pandemic is over
no one has been inside any of the
facilities where children are placed
there's currently almost 400 children
who are institutionalized around the
state and around the country
those children who are out of state are
only visited by dcyf once every three
months so people aren't inspecting the
buildings where they are they're not
making sure that the children feel
connected um and and in the last budget
deliberations
we had received a mandate to um you know
be sure that we were visiting children
from from this um committee in division
three um and because of
what happened with the budget veto and
then we were down a staff we weren't
able to fill and then the pandemic
happened we haven't been able to achieve
that so we anticipate a great deal of
travel this this coming year
do you have any unfunded positions
um no we had one position that was
frozen that just opened up and we're
just interviewing to fill that um next
week hopefully that will be filled soon
um so that would bring us up to
uh
five unclassified positions
um and uh and
right five fun classified now we're
asking for a six karen is that correct
sometimes um that once we fill that
position we would have um four
unclassified four yes and so we're
asking for a fifth
um
and there's also i should point out
there's an inconsistency
in line 11 for the um unclassified
position
where um the there's there's different
amounts when we were threatened in the
early negotiations with the budget we
were threatened with having to cut staff
and we noted that the salary for the
child advocate was listed in the budget
as much higher than
what's actually been paid and so we took
out that difference and so now it looks
as though there's actually a cut in pay
in the bienni in the next biennium
where we just kept it steady because it
hasn't been increased in three years
well i thank you i just say i am a huge
fan of you and your office and the work
you do and i have been since you arrived
and i am immensely relieved to see that
you are being as supported as you are by
the governor it's uh because so much
else has been caught and this is i'm
sure you feel like you're being deprived
in some ways every office head does but
let me tell you that compared to what
we've seen elsewhere in this budget um
i'm just relieved and i know you're a
small office it would have a huge impact
um but still you're coming out in in
much better shape than i was fearful of
so i'm i'm very happy for you
thank you representative waltz for your
kind words um and and we we are very
grateful um and we do believe that um
that we're able to play a role that's
that's significant and we think and the
position that we're filling next week is
a data analyst position and so we think
that we're going to be able to
demonstrate a lot more to folks with
that person and their ability
to show the cost savings across the
children's system um that we're able to
impact um with the work that we do so
we're looking forward to being able to
do that and we very much appreciate the
task before you we're you know if we
don't take it lightly when we're asking
for funds because we know that you have
a lot of difficult decisions to make we
appreciate that
i don't want your job
okay i don't want yours
other question from the committee
well i think that i think that
kind of wraps it up who have no
additional questions and you you seem
satisfied with your budget
we certainly are
so at this point
i would have i would move that we
approve the budget
okay do we have a second
i'll second that
okay we'll have a roll call
okay
all right we have we have a
motion to approve the budget if you're
in favor of respond yes if you're not in
february respond no
the clerk call the roll
okay um
i'm sorry chairman opened his app absent
um excused by the way uh vice chairman
yes
uh the clerk votes yes representative
griffin yes representative leishman
representative hatch yes
representative waltz yes
okay the vote is six nothing mr chairman
so it passes okay so your budget is
passed this committee
it will go to full finance
thank you all very much for your time
and your consideration i hope you all
have a good day
thank you okay so we will be in recess
until 10 o'clock
mr chair
tracy
mr chairman yes
hi this um
i'm sorry tracy i i um
i'll be gone for about an hour just an
fyi or so okay thank you
it's so dry in here okay we're gonna
bring in the uh representatives from the
board of tax and land appeals now okay
and we have uh michelle
lebron and
um
and stelmo
can you hear me now i think i was still
muted
i know we can hear you
okay good morning my name is michelle
lebrun i'm the chair of the board of tax
and land appeals
also in attendance is our clerk ann
stelmach who's available should there be
specific budgetary questions that she's
better suited
to respond to
we would like to thank you for allowing
us to
present our fiscal
2223 budget
the funding split for our budget is 90
percent general and 10
highway
um
i'm sure most of you know what we do but
in the event that there are new members
i'll just briefly explain
our enabling statute is rsa 71 b5 so the
board's jurisdiction is to hear and
determine all matters involving
questions of taxation
appeals by municipalities of their
equalized valuation that is determined
by the department of revenue
administration
just compensation
and eminent domain takings pursuant to
rsa 498-a and all matters related to
reassessments by municipalities
the parties are entitled to due process
and timely relief
many represent themselves we've heard
quite a few lately of parties that have
appeared pro se
to avoid the cost of counsel but we
certainly also hear a lot with
attorneys present
the board's budget is primarily a
maintenance budget
with additional prioritized needs at the
request of doit
and administrative services the
administrative services is rent and doit
is the shared cost
expense
with respect to the
questions posed by
the agents of the agency we are not
seeking any full-time or part-time staff
no positions were eliminated by the
governor's budgets
requirements
and at this time the agency is
adequately staffed to complete all of
our work that's assigned pursuant to the
statutes
we there is nothing found in the
statutes that the board would wish to
have eliminated
and
as far as house bill 2 we'd
looked through it and we didn't see
anything that applied to the board so
with that
we're requesting that you approve the
budget as submitted and if you have any
questions
please feel free to ask them
questions from the committee
okay
okay representative
yeah representative verge here um i have
a question and i
it involves preambulation i mean town
borders and whatnot that is an ongoing
problems and every time we want to
solve it we can't and the towns are
required to do that every 10 years to
walk the borders
is that something that you can address
or
are involved in
we are typically not involved in that
unless there is a dispute
and
a property is located on on a border um
but but no we are not
okay thank you
other questions from
the division anything
pretty straightforward budget again
some some agencies have 130 pages and
yours is nice and compact
well with no further questions
mr chairman yes
representative
mark closely at this so you go up by
about 200 and um
i'm sorry let me get the numbers right
20 40. i guess it's only 50 thousand
dollars i actually i have no question
the increase is so small it's de minimis
i have no question okay okay thank you
yeah
that would be nice
okay we have a motion to accept the
budget as submitted do we have second
so okay we're
we will have a roll call for the board
of tax and land appeals budget if you're
in favor you say yes if you're not in
favor say no
court will call the roll
okay
if the madam chairman is excused vice
chairman yes
the clerk votes yes
representative griffin yes
representative leishman yes uh
representative hatch is excused
represent walls yes
so the motion passes five to nothing
okay
[Music]
well that was short and sweet
thank you for coming
thank you very much i appreciate your
time
all right we and we will be adjusting
germs until 10 30.
welcome commissioner thank you for
coming
madam chairman we just lost all sound
was the one thing i've learned doing
this
is that we have absolutely no
way to hold a remote house session given
the daily amount of complaints we have
about
sound and access to things
are you can you hear us now
you shook her head yes
okay
thank you
uh
lindsay do you have any staff members
that you would like to join you remotely
via zoom
okay
great
so we'd like to
turn this over to you
and we're gonna not only go through what
you gave us but walk through some of
your budgets and we have some questions
and with my committee members we have
great questions so you're going to get
some really tough questions
welcome good morning madam chair
me the um to present the fiscal year
2022 and 2023
operating budget from the department of
graduate administration
with me today virtually our assistant
commissioner karen wear and business
administrator
shelbyville madam chair can we ask the
commissioner to turn on her microphone
please
pull it close to you as well
one of the problems we have in the room
i'll tell you quite honestly and it
there's no way to stop it but you see
this lovely piece of equipment here and
you can hear it there's a
pair to it in the back and the fans run
all the time i'm sure you can hear the
noise that ambient noise also goes
across all of our mics so we're trying
to pull the mics as close together as
possible so
thank you for doing that
will do hopefully representative walls
is that better
i think she said yes much better maybe
thank you okay
the mission of the dra is to fairly and
efficiently administer the tax laws of
the state of new hampshire collecting
the proper amount of taxes due while
incurring the lease cost to taxpayers in
a manner that merits the highest degree
of public confidence in our integrity
further we provide prompt and
constructive assistance to the municipal
units of government in matters of budget
finance and the appraisal of real estate
together we have developed a thoughtful
operating budget that will provide the
resources for our team to administer the
tax laws of our state for another two
fiscal years in a manner that is
consistent with this mission
as the primary revenue collection agency
we are certainly aware of the current
revenue picture and have worked hard to
produce a budget that's consistent with
the targets provided
in fiscal year 2020 the dra collected
2.2 billion in state revenue with a
total expense of less than 19.4 million
some of those expenses are for
activities unrelated to revenue
collections such as local assessments
and state aid
when those unrelated costs are accounted
for our cost of collection is three
quarters of one percent
the information included with this
testimony explains how we're able to
build the biennial budget that continues
to be an unparalleled return on state
tax dollar investment
we look forward to working with you and
developing this budget
next madam chair i'm going to move to
the questions that you provided thank
you and our answers certainly so
what new full-time staff has been added
to your budget there are no new
positions general funded or otherwise
that were added to the dra operating
budget
what new part-time staff have been added
there are no new part-time staff
positions added to the budget
what positions had to be eliminated in
order to meet the governor's budget
requirements
we have seven unfunded positions
that have been removed from the dra
operating budget
we've included the division position
number labor grade title and cost for
each position in the chart provided in
the letter
four of those positions are in the
taxpayer services division which helped
to timely process tax returns and
documents
i would note that the clerk 3 position
is currently unfunded in our current
budget and remains unfunded in the
governor's recommended budget
there is a municipal accounts auditor in
the municipal and property division that
person provides technical assistance to
municipal officials and establishes
property tax rates
lastly there are two multi-state tax
auditors in the audit division they
primarily audit large multinational
corporations for compliance with new
hampshire's tax laws
these two positions were new in our
fiscal year 2021 budget however they
were not filled prior to the kobit 19
pandemic and then we went into the
hiring freeze
so those positions remain unfilled the
estimated revenue for those positions
was zero dollars in fiscal year 20 as
they are training
and 1.5 million in fiscal year 2021.
how will work done by these positions be
accomplished without them the workload's
been distributed among the funded
positions within each division to ensure
each division meets their respective
missions as well as meeting the overall
mission of the department
is your agency adequately staffed to
complete all work assigned to your
agency yes we are
what things are you doing found in state
law that could be eliminated and why
gra runs a pretty lean operation we
don't have any programs that could be
eliminated
and were there any priorities that were
not funded all of our fun uh prioritized
needs were funded in the governor's
operating budget
last lastly lastly sections of hb2 we
have noted that there are a number
of sections that apply to the tax laws
which we administer
um however there are no changes that
would impact our operating budget and we
can administer the proposed changes to
the tax laws within our current
operating budget so i don't have any
concerns with what is included in house
bill 2.
questions from the
division before we move on
representation
scoot your microphone close to you
remember we are
this hybrid world is not working well
for meetings
so two years ago it was very important
to us as you recall to get those two
auditors to audit those out-of-state
larger companies
and it seems to me i know that they're
not included
and you mentioned what 1.5 million
dollars is a minimum they would bring in
would you advocate that we'd really
support those two positions to get that
additional funding are you still happy
not i'm you're not happy but not having
those two positions seems like
a foolish thing for us to not do sure
thank you for the question um certainly
the additional bodies would assist us
with generating the revenue um i will
note during the presentation we have a
high number of vacancies at this point
giving the hiring freeze
so
we will be we have unfilled positions
that are similar to those those
multi-state auditors we have unfilled
positions that are included in the
operating budget that we would hope to
fill during the biennium if the
additional positions were added we would
certainly do our best to fill those
positions as well but again we were
trying to be mindful of the targets that
were provided to us further follow up
thanks madam chair so how many vacant
funded positions do you have that's a
great question
you kind of walked into the question but
sure um and i was going to go over this
when we move on to the presentation but
we currently have 25 um vacant positions
out of 156
full-time funded positions so that's a
vacancy rate of about 16 wow that's
pretty significant uh thanks madam chair
well the corollary to that have you been
given permission to hire any of those
500 since the hiring freeze has
been right we have we are currently
recruiting for three positions um we
believe that we can fill those positions
and still meet our lapse requirements um
i am hopeful actually that some of those
positions will be internal promotions
and so we might be able to hire further
beyond that um and kind of move people
up through the organization okay why
don't we continue with your presentation
see no other questions at the moment
great so um slide two of the
presentation is just our mission
statement i read that during the opening
remarks so i will skip that
um slide three this is just a general
organizational chart uh just for folks
to understand what we do at the
department of revenue we have our
administration unit which includes all
of our back office functions
we have our audit division which does
exactly that there are primary auditors
for tax compliance within the
organization
our collections division
pursues
unpaid tax bills that are beyond their
appeal process
our taxpayer services division
handles all routine interactions with
the department so they're our primary
processing
unit for tax returns and tax forms that
we receive they also man our call center
so anytime you call into the dra and you
speak with our lovely call center
representatives there in the taxpayer
services division and this division also
um
does all of our account maintenance so
if you called in
wanting to move a payment
that sort of routine maintenance is done
within taxpayer services so if you're
not under audit and we're not looking to
collect from you your interactions are
primarily with our taxpayer services
division
lastly our municipal and property
division those are the folks that set
the tax rates review the assessments for
our municipal folks
they also administer the utility
property tax the timber tax and the
gravel tax
on slide four i've provided a big
picture overview of our fiscal year 22
23 budget compared to our fiscal year 21
budget
so you'll see i have broken it out by
general funds education trust funds and
agency income
our fiscal year 2022 budget is just over
a million dollars less than our fiscal
year 2021 budget for general funds
we're about 950 000 less in education
trust funds
and our agency income remains flat
throughout the biennium
in fiscal year 2023 or about 200 000
less in general funds than 950 000 less
in education trust fund and flat funding
for agency income
so you will see that the difference
between for the total budget for fiscal
year 2022 is just under 2 million
compared to fiscal year 21 and just
under 1.2 million or 1.1 million uh for
fiscal year 23 as compared to 21. so
that's an eight and a half percent
reduction in fiscal year 22 and a 5.4
reduction in fiscal year 23.
at the bottom you will see that our
position count remains static as i
mentioned we have not added any new
positions
but as i did note current funded
position count has decreased from 156
full-time classified and unclassified
positions in fiscal year 21 to 150
positions in fiscal years 22 and 23.
our general fund operating budget is 75
salary and benefits we are the
department of people not things or
programs
all of the positions that we propose to
unfund are currently vacant
and funding in our budget does include
the following positions that are
currently vacant but would generate
revenue
so you'll see there's about seven
hundred thousand dollars in fiscal year
22 and 3.2 million dollars in fiscal
year 23
that would be generated by currently
vacant positions that are funded in the
fiscal year 22 and 23 budget and we have
provided madam chair those numbers to
house ways and means so they are aware
of those anticipated revenues and just
so you know i did ask
chairman major in house ways and means
did he include this funding
in
his
revenue estimates the house voted on the
answer to that was no because it was not
current law and current law had them
unfunded
if i
go back to the questions you answered
the position numbers are in those
questions when we went through before
right yes they are correct okay thank
you you're welcome
moving on to slide five some things to
note about our operating budget
so our doit services and positions are
all maintained
the doit budget
costs are steady over the biennium but
they are reduced by approximately 8.7
percent compared to fiscal year 21.
funding for vendors such as our
equalization and tax rate setting vendor
and temporary keying services are
included
i have noted uh where those
live within the budget equalization and
tax rate setting contract amount has
been reduced to reflect updated contract
pricing
that can be found on page 159
and our temporary keying services
contract amount was reduced to reflect
actual costs over the past few years as
more and more documents are coming in
electronically we don't have the need
for those keying services so we have
kind of right-sized that appropriation
the budget also maintains operational
capabilities as we anticipate adjusting
resources for our new rims project
however we did eliminate our rims
consulting services and that is found on
page 153
the reason for that is um we had started
those services with our capital budget
appropriation those services have gone
very well and we have come in under
budget so we're able to continue with
the services without needing the funding
in our operating budget
other reductions
throughout the budget include in our
out-of-state travel employee training
overtime and current expense
these were due to meeting the targets
provided by the governor
the division director's business office
and other managers have worked very hard
to budget conservatively and accurately
requesting funds for true needs and not
wants
moving on to slide six
i wanted to highlight the low and
moderate property tax relief so this is
funded through the education trust fund
and it is property tax relief program
related to the statewide education
property tax
we have funded this
at 800 000 in both fiscal year 22 and
23.
this is another example of kind of right
sizing the appropriation i've include
the i've included the program costs over
the past three years and you'll see that
the costs of the program have decreased
so we adjusted the funding within the
budget from the education trust fund to
reflect what we believe to be the true
cost of the program so we didn't want to
over appropriate in this instance
next on slide seven one of my favorite
topics um flood control
oh good because that's one of ours too
we're gonna ask questions so you could
see those questions coming yes
so our budget includes eight hundred and
eighty seven thousand dollars
uh 256 000 from the general fund and 630
000 from other funds in fiscal year 22
and the same amount in fiscal year 23
and that can be found on page 160.
this program reimburses cities and towns
for lost property taxes resulting from
property acquired in the acquisition of
land by the united states for navigation
and flood control so these are the
merrimack river valley compact and the
connecticut river valley compacts
the budget does assume that
massachusetts will reimburse their share
of 70 percent of the merrimack river
valley compact as well as 50 percent of
the connecticut river valley compact and
that connecticut will reimburse their
share of 40 of the connecticut river
valley compact
as you likely know there's a long
history of massachusetts not paying its
obligation timely or sufficiently for
the
merrimack river valley compact there is
currently just shy of 3 million dollars
currently outstanding for fiscal years
15 through 20. payments up to fiscal
year 14 have been settled in an
agreement with massachusetts
the governor is authorized to draw a
warrant for the payment of such
reimbursements out of money in the
treasury that is not otherwise
appropriated
we estimate that the warrant that will
be issued for fiscal year 21 is just
over six hundred thousand dollars
i would note the governor's office and
uh the attorney general's office uh are
very much aware of this issue and it is
my understanding um that they are
working on trying to resolve these
amounts due from the commonwealth of
massachusetts
absolutely
so thanks for your thorough presentation
on that last night i received an email
from ann rice at the attorney general's
office we had inquired
earlier in the day about the status of
the flood control
and she pointed out that they're working
diligently however
they're still waiting for arbitrators to
be appointed
and has no idea when that might happen
so the likelihood
you correctly stated
in her email
she also said it's been since 2014 so it
certainly doesn't look like we're going
to get any of that money soon manager i
think i sent you an
a copy of her email but
i think you should probably know that it
doesn't look good
but thanks for your presentation that
was my understanding as well that we're
working on it but it's not maybe going
to be anytime soon can we bring this to
a final resolution it's my understanding
there could be a one-time settlement
right and that is what we um that we did
settle up to 14 and so there i think
could be the opportunity to settle for
the amounts due from 15 through 20 and
likely 21
but the best way to do that would
probably be a question directed rightly
at the attorney general's office
can you ask ann edwards that you started
that email training
i think part of the problem in
massachusetts right now is they don't
have any more money we have plus they
sent home all the workers who work out
of state and new hampshire is one of the
states suing them because of their state
law that said if you're working at home
you don't have to pay taxes so now
everybody's working at home because you
locked them out
right
okay on slide eight i just did want to
give a couple updates on the priorities
from our fiscal year 2021 budget
the first is what the result are first
is our new revenue information system or
rims
as you may know dra received a 30
million 160 000 capital appropriation
through general funds and other funds to
replace our old uh software system
we entered into a contract with fast
enterprises on october 31st 2018 to
implement the commercial off-the-shelf
software gen tax
that cost is just under 30 million
roll out one we have three rollouts
rollout one went live on october 28 2019
with the meals and rentals tax medicaid
enhancement tax and nursing facility
quality assessment
rollout 2 went live in the middle of a
pandemic on october 5th 2020 with our
largest tax types the business profits
tax business enterprise tax interest and
dividends tax and communication services
tax
and then rollout three is on schedule to
go live on august 9 2021 with our
remaining tax types the real estate
transfer tax tobacco tax utility
property tax gravel tax timber tax
railroad and private car taxes
rollout 1 and rollout 2 were very
successful as i mentioned even in the
middle of a pandemic rollout 2 was on
time on budget the team adapted very
quickly to being remote they all left
the office and have been working at home
ever since
and they worked very hard and we've been
very successful
the current contract includes four years
of support and maintenance on the system
after rollout three with optional
extensions those will be paid by capital
funds the optional extensions we will
need to start working those funds into
our operating budget
representative you have a question thank
you thank you for taking my question
pull that close
the uh thank you
does this mean if you're if you're
paying quarterly
uh
uh interest and dividends payments you
can do it online now that is correct
okay you can do that online you're also
able to log create an account and log in
and see your account so if you don't
remember what you paid last quarter in
the past you'd have to call dra and have
us look up your account and confirm for
you your payment you'll be able to do
that all on your own now just like you
can with your own bank account okay so
there's great taxpayer functionality
with a web facing portal good thank you
thank you manager
[Music]
um and then lastly on page nine the rims
health assessments i mentioned this was
a cost that was previously included in
our operating budget
it was a prioritized need from last
budget of 340 000
to assist dra with periodic project
health assessments
barry dunn is our vendor for that as i
mentioned the assessments have gone very
well and so we don't need the operating
budget funding we've been able to cover
all of the assessments all the way
through rollout three within our capital
budget they have completed six project
health assessments so far all of which
gave the project an overall score of a
five or outstanding with no actions or
changes recommended so we really have
had a very successful project with rims
lastly i'll just mention and we have
touched upon this already
in
the final fiscal year 2020 2021 budget
there were additional positions in the
audit division that were included
there was an in-state and multi-entity
auditors funded for both 20 and 21
there were two multi-state auditors for
half of fiscal year 20 and all of 21 and
then an additional multi-state auditor
funded just for fiscal year 2021.
all of these positions may remain
unfilled by the time the budget finally
passed the positions were generated
within the system
we were coming into the january february
time frame pandemic hit and we were
unable to hire
um
as we mentioned and talked about there
are two multi-state auditor positions
that are unfunded in 22 and 23 as i
previously noted
that is all i have madam chair i'm happy
to answer any questions
commissioner is there anything in your
line item budget that you would like to
talk about or that is changed or
beyond what your presentation was and
again you're like
most of our state agencies for this
biennium you have cut positions cut
spending and are moving forward with
belt tightening given the pandemic
that is an accurate statement i have
noted for you in the presentation what i
believe are all the large fluctuations
that you would see
in the budget
as i mentioned there are a few other
instances where you'll see current
expense or employee training has changed
and that is as you mentioned adam chair
the belt tightening but the large
changes should be referenced in the
presentation so i think um we have
covered most of that
representation thanks madam chair
so either you or john beardmore prepared
for us several years back the breakdown
of the flood control towns and the
payments
so what the state would be sending to
say hopkinton or peterborough whatever
could you do that again sure for that
hundred what's it six hundred and
sixteen thousand dollars and what that
breakdown would be sure happy to do that
thanks madam chair you're welcome and i
think that's important
uh commissioner before we got started
i don't see any other questions right
now but i had asked a
question about
ppe loans
i think everybody in the legislature has
probably heard from one or more
constituents about ppe loans and i know
you're going to you said you'd send me
something right and i would like it but
i would also i think like to talk about
that
a little bit while we have the public on
because we do have two representatives
at home
who did not hear that conversation
we also have
a few attendees
so when we started what i said to the
commissioner was i'm a small business i
got a hundred thousand dollars in a ppe
loan
and it became both a debit and a credit
because i had a loan and then i had a
credit because i had a hundred thousand
but then i applied for the loan
forgiveness i was given the loan
forgiveness that loan now turned into
only a credit and a grant
so i no longer had a loan that i had to
pay back so my debit went away but i
still had a grant of a hundred thousand
dollars and my question was what is the
tax implication on that and this is
apparently two part there's something
the feds are doing which is above and
beyond what the state is doing as well
as what the state is doing so
commissioner if you could just run
through that because i heard uh
representative griffin representative
leishman were both interested i have a
feeling that our two representatives at
home might have the same interest and we
have some time sure i'm happy to go
through that so yes madam chair so let's
assume that there is a ppp loan of a
hundred thousand dollars
if and when that loan is forgiven you're
correct it becomes a grant
for state tax purposes that hundred
thousand dollars is going to be included
in gross income
any expenses
that were paid with that grant and again
ppp is payroll protection there are
likely wages that were paid with that
money any other normal operating
business expenses to keep your business
open and operating those expenses are
deductible so you would see a hundred
thousand dollars come in in gross income
and then likely a hundred thousand
dollars being deducted for wages and
normal operating business expenses
that means the result impact to
your net income to which you would apply
the business profits tax rate would be
zero
so so long as the amounts were spent on
deductible expenses there would be no
business profits tax implications there
would be no business profits tax due
that's at the state level now let's talk
about the federal treatment
there was a lot of
back and forth with how this was going
to be treated federally but the outcome
was that
that hundred thousand dollar grant
although any other grant would be
included in gross income that hundred
thousand dollar ppp grant the feds have
said you don't include that in gross
income
so it's not going in your gross income
but you can still deduct the expenses
that you used or that you paid for with
that money so if you spent the hundred
thousand dollars on wages those wages
are still deductible
so that is an additional benefit and
will further reduce
the taxes that you owe at the federal
level
so again it's a benefit that the federal
government has provided to those folks
that have received a ppp loan
senate bill 3 is currently in the senate
has passed out of the ways and means
committee has not yet gone to the floor
senate bill 3 would have the state
following the federal treatment where
that additional benefit would be
provided to ppp
to businesses that received ppp and that
loan was forgiven so those that have ppp
grants would have this beneficial tax
treatment that's essentially what senate
bill 3 does
and as i mentioned madam chair and i'm
happy to share with the committee um
i'll send to the committee there is a
tax information release or a tir that's
available on our website that walks
through this we've also put out
a press release
to help get this information out about
the difference in the federal and the
state tax treatment
thank you there are questions on that
representative are you raising your hand
i yes i am i just did thank you um so
you talked about the bpt what about the
b-e-t is there an effect on that
so the um bet if the ppp loan was paid i
used to pay wages those wages would be
subject to the bet
thank you
does senate bill 3
senate bill 3 does not address bet okay
it only addresses bpt
i guess i have it
represented
please
so now what about the main street grants
or i thought you were going to ask that
next that's that's a great question
this treatment is only for ppp
it is not for main street grants it's
not for
the self grants it's not for any other
grants this treatment is only for ppp
and so this beneficial treatment would
only be available to those
that received ppp
and we know that there may be a lot of
reasons why a business didn't receive
ppp um and so there there is potent
there is a fairness issue here it would
only be benefiting those that received
ppp and if your business did not receive
ppp you would follow the normal tax
treatment
but again if the amounts are spent on
deductible expenses there really should
be no impact there should be no tax
impact
any other questions
can i just to follow up walls yes
when you say there should be no taxable
impact does that mean in the bet too
because that they would be able to
deduct the wages that they paid so
there's no taxable impact there no sorry
i'm speaking about bpt
only only bpt right so they would be
grants would come in gross income any
amount spent on deductible expenses
would be a deducted out and therefore
the impact for bpt would be minimal so
long as the amounts were spent on
deductible expenses
that was how i initially understood it i
just wanted to be make sure i wasn't
convoluting things sure thank you
yeah
busy very busy
i am inclined to
fund those positions
and get the revenue
and i have already emailed while we're
sitting here lba and asked them to do
that
so lindsay we're not going to take any
action on this budget at this time i
don't know when we will get our
amendment
but
thank you you heard what we said yes
thank you madam chair members of the
committee i really appreciate it
thank you yes you do thank you
see no other questions i want to thank
you for coming this morning spending
time with us i want to thank you for
being so well prepared and
thank you it's nice to see everybody in
person yes
yes we're very happy that vaccines are
out and we've started getting vaccinated
and
it's even nicer that the cdc is
recognizing that
there is a positive impact because i
have a little bit of a breathing problem
and so getting a mask off every now and
then went on with people who are not
who are vaccinated has been a blessing
wonderful wonderful
thank you thank you very much
i don't even know if i have a
at 11.
okay
we're right on time
so
we're going to now move to page 164
which is community development
and i think we have the director of
community development now with us as a
panelist good morning
good morning yes this is katie easterly
marty the executive director of the
community development finance authority
thank you for having me
we're happy you're here so what page are
we on for
one
one 164 if you're trying to follow us at
home and you have a budget book
and you just
don't know what to do with all the stuff
page 164.
katie thank you for coming and please
jump into your budget presentation for
us
absolutely thank you for this
opportunity to address you regarding our
one line in the state treasury
department's budget for fiscal years 22
and 23 which is new hampshire's required
for the administrating the federal
community development block grant
program
cdfa is a
independent nonprofit organization and
as such our board is appointed by the
governor and council as a state
authority we are among a handful of
unique entities that work in partnership
with the state and federal initiative to
strengthen new hampshire's communities
through the distribution of resources to
municipalities non-profits and
businesses
i am here to request a continued match
funding from the state of new hampshire
in the amount of four hundred thousand
dollars over the next biennium the
request of two hundred thousand dollars
per year represents the federally
required match of state funds towards
program administration for new
hampshire's annual allocation of federal
block grant resources under the cdbg
program
under the state cdbg programs program
state awards
grants to smaller units of general local
government that develop and preserve
decent affordable housing provide
services to the most vulnerable in our
communities and create and retain jobs
annually each state new hampshire and
we do this in partnership for new
hampshire develop the funding priorities
and criteria for selected projects
the department of housing and urban
development uses a formula to allocate
these resources and if funding levels
remain similar to years in past we
anticipate that new hampshire's total
cdbg allocation over the next biennium
will be approximately 18.6 million
dollars
cdfa provides the state with
exceptionally cost efficient system for
providing these resources to communities
cdfa is financially self-sufficient and
relies on fees from the from the
programs we administer plus this state
match
to meet our budget needs the cdbg
program is focused on the development of
viable sustainable and
communities by providing decent housing
suitable living environments expanding
economic opportunities
and the cdbg program is focused
primarily on low and moderate income
people cdbg projects in new hampshire
have leveraged tens of million of
dollars in matching capital
all eligible new hampshire
municipalities and counties have the
opportunity to access
up to 1.5 million dollars in resources
to support projects
annually in addition to requests for
emergency and planning resources we
support a lot of planning activities
that lead to these important community
driven efforts that local leaders and
community members say are necessary
within their municipality or region
cdfa staff administer competitive grant
rounds throughout the year all on all
applications undergo extensive
programmatic and financial review by
cdfa
in addition projects that meet all
necessary criteria are voted on by an
independent 11-member community
development advisory committee and then
confirmed by cdfa's 11 member board of
directors
all of the 22
individuals new hampshire citizens who
review and approve these projects are
appointed by the governor and council
and represent a number of different
sectors and communities involved in
community development
once cdfa's board recommends funding the
proposed awards are sent to the governor
and council executive council for final
approval
federal office funds come with
significant requirements cdfa's
professional staff train and provide
technical assistance to our grantees
throughout the process including in
pre-application application and
implementation phases of the projects
we're really happy that
communities of all sizes access the cdbg
uh funds
we work closely with partners to find
creative solutions and offer guidance on
project development as well as to ease
the burden of compliance and protect the
investment of the taxpayer dollars
in calendar years 2018 and 2019 funds
from the state's cdbg program have
improved the lives of
2455 people through public facility
improvements and 613 people through
emergency grants
created or retained 98 livable wage jobs
with benefits and created or
rehabilitated 260 affordable and
workforce housing units we've also
provided technical assistance to 200 602
very small businesses and those small
businesses have been able to grow their
wages and actually
90 of those involved in that program
have moved from being low-income to now
their family is no longer low income and
a testament to the importance of this
investment in the lives of low income
people
cdb cdfa respectfully requests the state
of new hampshire continue to provide the
federally required match a total of four
hundred thousand dollars for the 2022
and 2023 state fiscal years by doing so
we can deploy approximately
18.66 million dollars of resources into
new hampshire's community economic
development projects that are critical
to so many communities i thank you for
considering this request and i'm happy
to answer any questions that you have
any questions from the members
cnn this budget is the only thing it has
in it is the two hundred thousand dollar
match which is flat funded there we do
not pay staff for benefits or anything
else
and so this is i think katie has
explained very clearly why she needs the
funds
i believe we could probably approve this
budget if you guys are in agreement
represent emrick moves to approve
community development block grant
representative griffin seconds
is there any discussion on the motion
when the clerk is ready
he may call the roll
okay madam chairman yes vice chairman
the clerk votes yes representative
griffin yes representative lischmann yes
representative hatch is excused absent
represent walls
yes and i just want to say i wish
everything had that same kind of rate of
return as this that's extraordinary
thank you
the vote is six nothing
that motion passes unanimously katie
thank you for spending the morning with
us thank you for being so well prepared
thank you so much i wish you the rest of
your day
um
lba i would like to put up
[Music]
amendment number 2021-06738
proposed by
representative leishman
and would you tell me when it is
available so i know that
our members at home have access to it
yes we'll look for it right now thank
you
it's up now mike
um it will be shortly okay just tell me
what's up we're not gonna start till
it's up no hurry
it's up madam chair you should see it
okay i do we do i actually don't well i
guess it's okay if it's on screen so
mary beth you have it at home now you
can get it from the dra website as well
i'm going to turn this over to
representative leishman this is an
amendment
to hb2
representative leichmann
madam chair or nancy can we have this
zoomed in some it's thank you
yeah a little bit better
how about a little bit how's that
perfect thank you okay
thanks madam chair um
and i will turn very quickly to house
bill 2 i believe this is section 9.
um looking for the page page six
so this changes the language you'll see
presently on section nine where it says
the fiscal committee
of the general court may approve changes
to the above plan design cost sharing
provisions consistent with rsa 21-i
colon 3
i found the language a little
problematic if you go to the judicial
council there's similar
language to my amendment so what i'm
looking to do
um in line seven
starting after the comma
one or i
which is part of the rsa
again everyone seen that on line seven
are permitted with the prior approval
the fiscal committee of the general
court so i just think it clears up the
language a little bit from the existing
section nine
so the purpose of this
is to ensure that there is no confusion
about the role of the fiscal
committee of the general court that's
correct madam chair any discussion by
any member
seeing on representative leashman might
i assume that you move adoption of
amendment 2021-0-6-7-3-h
thanks madam chair i would
representative emerick seconds the
motion to adopt amendment 2021-06738
when the clerk is ready
he may call the roll
okay thank you madam chairman yes the
vice chairman
the clerk votes yes representative
griffin yes representative leishman yes
representative hatch is excused
represented walls yes
okay the motion is six nothing the
motion passes six to nothing
can i ask that
lba would remove this motion this
amendment and you would post amendment
h which is about
is the amendment for the banking
commissioner which we discussed when he
was here
madam chair what section of house bill 2
is that amending
you'll see it when it comes up
thank you
i'm passing out paperwork
i believe that's a new section
yes
at the end that's being added
thank you
so this would
effectively be i have to open my hb2
i think the last section is
very long can you read the i'm sorry i'm
checking the last section would be
representative walls let me answer one
of your questions at a time this would
be section 287 because this is a new
section added at the end
and nancy when you get that up
representative wallace will be able to
see the number and the verbage can you
i'm sorry can you just read the
amendment number again please
two 2021
zero six three five h
i i believe i have it on the screen but
once i share once i share the screen i
can't see it
oh terrific
how's this how's the size look
looks good
all right this is the section
that
mr little discussed with us in depth
that public deposit investment pool
where he felt like he had a conflict of
interest because he was supposed to be
protecting and then it looked like he
was working
kind of against the people he was
supposed to be protecting and he
proposed this language which we
discussed
at the time and asked that it be added
to hb2
as an amendment in order to provide
proper protection for the banking
commissioner
it also allows him to charge
appropriately
so that the customers
that he's supposed to be protecting are
not paying for it but that the public
pool is paying for
the expenses
yes
you can go ahead
representative leishman i mean i'm sorry
representative moves the adoption of
amendment two zero two one
zero six
three five h representative leishman
seconds is there any discussion on the
motion
so two not
madam chair represent walls
to be clear this simply changes how it's
paid for all we're doing is moving
how this is paid for am i correct that
is correct if you recall
commissioner little did not have a way
to appropriately
have the
public deposit investment pool
pay for the cost of his involvement and
instead it was being charged to his
customers so he feels that this is a
fairer situation provides the
appropriate protection allows him to do
the job he's supposed to do and protect
his customers
i do recall his testimony thank you for
recounting it
when the clerk is ready you may call the
rule
madam chairman yes
vice chairman yes the clerk votes yes
representative griffin representative
lischmann representative
hatch as an excuse absent
represent walls
yes
uh representative hatch is here uh sir
uh um
yes yes
okay
i apologize i didn't know you were here
okay i'm in my car now okay
yes okay great the vote is seven nothing
and unanimous madam chairman
okay that motion passes we're going to
turn to page 26
and hb2
section
and i'm asking lba to bring up
amendment number
two zero
two one
zero seven
zero six
h
thank you
for those of us looking at this
amendment
section 57 was
proposed by the department of
corrections and consisted of
lines 12
through 17.
plus the titles found in lines 6 through
11.
in conversation with commissioner hanks
it was agreed that the titles in section
and you notice it's only a few titles
could have in line 10
15 years
experience
prior to the appointment
so it adds section one
with her blessing
leaves
her language for the others to ten years
have i passed that out
no
duh
he's so happy
you're right i am
just a moment a failure of the chair to
pass out the amendment to committee
members
yes thank you
representative emerick moves the
adoption of 2021-0706-h
represent griffin's seconds the motion
is there any discussion
seeing none when the clerk is ready you
may call the roll
madam chairman
yes
vice chairman the clerk votes yes
representative griffin yes represent
representative hatch yeah
represent walls yes
junior animus 7-nothing madam chairman
thank you
okay now we're going to turn to
hb2
section 52
page 24.
the amendment number which i am not
going to hoard this time
is 2021-0739
h
okay we now have it up on the screen
thank you to lba who's providing
excellent service to us as always
okay this
amendment makes one slight
change to this section
on line 22
as proposed the fund would have been
non-lapsing and continuously
appropriated however that language has
been removed
one of the things we discovered
when
governor hassan vetoed the min the
budget was that things that were
continuously
approved continued being spent without
any input from
the legislature and i think on both
sides last year when representative
lovejoy was
chairing division one and now we made an
effort to take that out and leave things
as it was and i
thought she was doing the right thing
and i followed along with that
any questions on the
amendment
representative emerick moves the
adoption of 2021-73
represent griffin's seconds
any discussion on the motion
mr clerk when you are ready for the roll
call
okay thank you madam chairman yes
yes well i'm sorry madam chairman vice
votes yes madam i mean i didn't have my
mic on i'm sorry the vice chairman votes
yes the clerk votes yes representative
griffin yes reference leashman yes
representative hatch
yay
the representative walls yes
7-0 unanimous madam chairman motion is
adopted unanimously
i had some sections in hb2
i wanted lba to
walk us through
let's see if i can find the numbers i
want
because we have a few minutes
peter you're not ready with your
amendment on section 19 is that correct
is that that late nancy is working on it
nancy's working on that okay we will
avoid that till we get that
could lba help us with section 51 which
we did not adopt
page 24. it is an agricultural
section
and as i understand this this amendment
is only adding the division of pesticide
control
is that correct
yes this is mike hoffman looking at
section
51 the previous language said the fund
shall only be used to support the
purposes of the integrated pest
management program
this ads
and the division of pesticide control
so it expands uh the availability of
that fund to the division and not just
the program
that seems
okay to me is there anybody have any
problem with this i
i can't remember why we didn't do it
while the commissioner was here
i just haven't rubbed his own walls
please i'm not sure anybody knows the
answer to this but i it does jump at me
and that is integrated pest management
suggests it may or may not include
chemicals division of pesticide control
pesticides or chemicals and i'm
wondering if this is some sort of
significant policy change of moving from
organic to chemical control
i know
it's the addition of a division for
funding purposes so that was taken out
of general funds
okay just i didn't know the implications
of it and if perhaps that's what this
meant and that's my only question
is your motion to approve section
representative emerick moves to approve
section 51 representative griffin
seconds to motion
sir clerk
it will be your turn when you're ready
okay thank you madam chairman yes vice
chairman yes the clerk votes yes
representative griffin yes
representative leishman yes
representative hatch
yes
representative walsh yes motion 7 7-0
unanimous
motion passes
could lba walk us through section 55.
um
i think nancy you told me this section
was
a little convoluted
yes um
we probably why we didn't do anything
with it yeah i can uh try to screen
share some of the information that i
provided
previously
um just bear with me
the question was i said you know why
don't we just delete this because
they've got less money the rooms and
meals taxes down we don't need it
and then it was like well what are we
really deleting nancy started looking
into the history it was pretty
convoluted so i thought i'd have her
share with us what she found before we
do anything we're not voting this today
this is just for us to think about
this this section has been suspended for
a number of bienniums and it it
it credits support to the meals and
rooms tax
based on a budget um from several
bienniums ago where the ruins and meals
tax was
increased in a portion of it 3.15
of the
total collection net of expenses was
allocated for the budget of this
division
and
each time
we try to verify that amount we kind of
run into a brick wall
i've contacted a number of departments
to verify what exactly that amount is
and um it is net of expenses that the
department of revenue
um has for collecting that tax which is
a calculation they have to do based on
the amount of tax they collect for all
taxes
there's a letter issued to the treasury
and then that is shared with the
department and the
governor's office and you see line items
for this item in your budget but there's
also an expense for the education trust
fund that's backed out debt service
and the calculation is done at the time
before
figures are audited so it's kind of a
moving target
and um
our calculations are are somewhat dated
so i have asked the department that
administers
division of travel and tourism to verify
the numbers in the budget i've asked the
governor's office to verify that they in
turn have asked the department of
administrative services
and they're going to circle back to the
department of revenue
the short answer is that this um
this uh amount that was allocated as i
stated based on a um
increase in the rooms and meals tax was
done a number of years ago
as you well know that the governor has
now um
proposed decreasing that
act so
this figure will be in flux again in the
next biennium
and uh i am still working to get an
accurate number for what the statutory
uh amount for this division is
regardless of what it what appears in
the budget there is a firm calculation
but i have not received it yet
okay thank you we're not taking any
action on that i just want you to know
it's a lot more complicated than you
might think from those two or three
lines
i did ask
uh
mr hoffman yesterday because now i want
to turn to page 40.
section
which leads into
something that we have to discuss
almost every
biennium and who wants to talk about
that
uh
section 77
uh changes the
cap for the rate uh revenue
stabilization fund
currently it's based on
general fund unrestricted revenue for
the most recently completed fiscal year
this would change it to the most
recently completed fiscal biennium
which would
assuming even revenues in each year
would double the cap
adam chair is this the rainy day fund
yes
thank you
so we haven't done anything with that
i'm not proposing we do something with
it right now but i wanted to know if the
division had
questions
that we should be thinking about
because we're going to have the
governor's budget director in
at one point to talk to us
and i think he will have
probably
some questions and some things to say to
us about that but if we're going to have
questions on it i wanted to get
that out
as soon as i could
to him
any questions
okay so we'll just
think about think about that
um i think i have some
hb1 amendments
i gotta tell you this is so much easier
when lba is in the room and you can say
hey nance and mike do we have an
amendment on hb1 or something and they
can say well would you like to do this
or would you like to do that and you can
just
say yes and they hand it out for you
all right
um
mike and nancy these are going to be
more difficult
i need to put up the errata sheet
technical corrections to source of funds
this is not general funds this is the
department of labor they brought this to
our attention
when they were here
can you put that up on the screen for me
bingo thank you
all right if you recall
when mr maryfield was here he pointed
out
that
agency income not general funds but
agency income
two of them just got swapped
and not
keyed in the right line
so this is
the adjustment to make that happen no
change in funding no change in bottom
line of the budget and just swap one
thing
for another
representative emerick moves to accept
the hb1 amendment to labor the errata
sheet is their second representative
griffin seconds
mr clerk i bet you know what it's your
turn
he is
he's like this is too much paper
oh heaven room is wonderful
we are set okay
um your vote madam chairman yes
uh
vice chairman
of the clerk votes yes representative
griffin yes referendum leashman yes
representative hatch
yes vote riverton walls yes
okay the voters unanimous seven nothing
great
okay and now guys we have a harder one
nancy and mike
can you bring up the
doc
restore funds for educational and
vocational programs
amendment please
you got your steps today
did i not give you enough
oh no no i was talking about the roll
call sheet
which i'm gonna fill out
when we take a break
okay just i'm going to have lba
walk us through this but a little
background
when department of corrections was here
this division discovered that the
educational vocational programs had been
unfunded in the doc
i have said to helen that
we have money to put it back
and i wanted her to do a deep dive on
how she wanted it spread out and what
she needed to match the amount of money
that she was being given
this was
the top piece
is give it was
given to lba
and they worked on this this is a
two-page attachment because the
attachment is in order to fund this
what i have done
i'm hoping that
ways and means revenues are
too low
and we all know that we won't have the
march revenues nor will we have the
april which is when the business taxes
come in and we usually have a really big
month so i have taken the money
which is general fund dollars from the
governor's
scholarship fund i have left the lines
open
so that as this will have passed out of
us before that comes so the senate can
just flow the money back into that
transferred the money over to doc i
talked to the governor's budget director
this morning
he said that they had had
a great deal of difficulty when they
made that cut themselves and he
understood where we were going and he
appreciated leaving the two scholarship
lines open because they think as i think
that the economy is recovering and we
are going to see more revenue but we
have to go with the house ways and means
which was unanimous and those guys are
the experts and they're doing what they
have right now which i greatly respect
and i just tend to be a little more
optimistic about the future they can't
afford to be optimistic they have to be
accurate so their approach is a little
different so this is two page amendments
what we have lba would you walk us
through first the corrections piece
yes
that's the first page that you should
see on your screen
and this would restore funding the 21
positions that were unfunded
in the education and vocation programs
this information was provided by the
commissioner
and you'll see the general phone totals
of
approximately 2.5 million in each year
and then if i turn to the next page
you'll see the
governor scholarship
account
and that's going to be on line 107
which is reduced and there's a dollar
left to hold the
class line open
i think everybody in the division
thought we should have
education in the prisons i know we were
sued over that i don't think prisoners
can
develop skills to lead a meaningful life
if we can't provide some training
representation
yes madam chair i just like to thank you
and
certainly we all recognize the
importance of this
and
the fact that you
have taken such a positive stance i just
want to say that's very much appreciated
thank you
representative madam chair
just a moment represent walls
representative emerick is moving the
package of the amendment for the
department of corrections and the
amendment for the treasury treasury
representative griffin is seconding
we're open for for questions
representative walsh you have your hand
up please proceed i do thank you um so
i i'm assuming that what's not in here
is the transitional housing units all
we're restoring is the educational
monies is that correct that is correct
okay by the way i do want to enter
echo what representative leitchman said
i was shocked by these cuts and i am so
pleased that you are working to restore
them so i i just want to say that as
well i think these are crucial um thank
you
so
okay so i'm as concerned about
transitional housing as you are but it
was kind of like one step at a time
sure and i appreciate that thank you i
just wanted to make sure i clearly it's
hard to see these on the screen and
particularly this is the first time
we're seeing them i wanted to be sure i
understood what we're seeing
the first time i'm seeing it as well so
yes
thank you so as well so i have two
questions one is the second page numbers
look like they're smaller than the first
page numbers
um maybe i'm misreading it they're a
little larger
no it looks like we're taking
we're spending more than we're taking is
what i'm suggesting maybe i'm not
misreading it but i look like if you if
you look at the change column
um you have house introduced and then
change
and then it
and we're looking at the bottom of
treasury right now we are are taking out
2.9 million if you look at corrections
nancy or mike if you can bring up
corrections
if you look at the it's in the same
format we are spending two point two
million four hundred and seventy nine
thousand dollars so we are
taking
a little more than we are spending i am
aware we have a the transitional housing
issue and some other issues but this is
that's what we have so we are spending
less than we are taking ever so slightly
now i see it thank you um
my second question is is that as i
recall
um there was a total of an eight million
dollar cut to the corrections budget
if this looks like a restoring five
total so
an additional three million dollar cut
i guess that's primarily the
transitional housing without seeing the
whole no that's actually not right if
you go one more column over
there was a larger amount of money
in the education than we're restoring
however the other thing i've done since
corrections was here remember they came
the first day i called helen and asked
her
if she could call commissioner edelblue
at department of education
because we have an online virtual
charter school that provides
some late elementary classes
and all of the high school classes
and with the new
women's prison
it was designed with an opportunity to
be able to take advantage of some of
that online
education as well for people trying to
get either their ged or finish out their
high school diploma she has reached out
to him
and she is also going to be using v-lacs
so there is a difference between what
she originally presented to the governor
with no velocs and what we're restoring
in the funding so she is giving up about
a million
point four in educational funding as
well
okay thank you for that explanation
because that was not obvious looking at
this i appreciate no it's not i'm sorry
thank you for asking i've had so many
phone calls
trying to work out some of these things
to fund some things that i'm losing my
mind
there isn't enough wine in the world
that's how i'm going to put it
thank you
okay
i know we have a motion on the floor to
approve the doc
restoration funds for educational
programming in conjunction with the
governor's scholarship fund made by
representative emerick second by
representative griffin
if you're in favor of the motion when
the clerk calls your name
please vote yes if no please vote no
madam chairman yes
uh vice chairman yes the clerk votes yes
representative griffin yes
representative leishman yes
representative hatch yes represent walls
yes
vote seven nothing unanimous madam
chairman thank you
[Music]
okay i have a technical corrections for
admin services
which i am seen for the first time
but i'm going to ask lba
to bring it up i'm not even going to be
able to speak to this i know that
charlie
sent this in
he did tell us in his presentation it
was coming
but i don't remember quite all the
details
okay so whoever in
can i address that
there are nancy absolutely
there are three pages which amount to a
combined
uh 600 and 8 000 in fy 22 and 631 000
and fy
23 and what this is
is a reallocation of sorts of funds
for a budgetary transfer for maintenance
of buildings in
that are occupied by other agencies
and normally
and those agencies already have this
built into their agency transfers so
there's no corresponding change here but
it was misclassified
in the budget as general funds and it
should have been
classified
as transfers from other agencies so
there are no impact to those agencies
but it does reduce the general fund
sorts of fund within the das budget and
increases the transfer line so the
agency nets that amount in general fund
dollars
and that was their request during their
presentation
though there are three different
entities
uh the department of revenue the
department of state and the department
of natural cultural resources
again no impact to those agency budget
lines because it's already been budgeted
in their transfer lines appropriately
but truly in a rat out here
a representative emerick moves the
administrative services errata sheet for
the technical corrections representative
emmerich seconds is there any
conversation questions represent walls
and lba nancy you're going to answer
this i hope i'm good
no mary beth
thank you so they're
what is the effect really on das and
their spending so this is 600 000 of
general funds it's coming back to them
do they get to spend it to make some of
that 15 cut or was that oh yes they do
and i have an amendment for that if we
approve this the next one you're going
to see is we're giving that money back
to them for some of those positions
charlie wanted
that thank you that was my question
that was easy
okay did she talk enough you can call
the roles her clerk yes
all right madam chairman yes votes
uh vice chairman yes the clerk votes yes
representative griffin yes
representative leishman
representative hatch
yes
representative walls
vote seven zero
it's unanimous okay so the last thing
we're gonna do before lunch
ah
this is called the additional need from
das and this is long and i'm just seeing
this now
mr clerk
and i am passing it out
i have to apologize to the division for
being an hour late this morning i had to
go to a meeting with the speaker and the
governor
but i know that representative emerick
did an absolutely magnificent job while
i was gone
and represented burj wants to know we
need emotion that reverse of immigrant
did a magnificent job
all right
nancy
i know you worked like a yeoman on this
one as well so
i'm going to turn it over to you i will
say
there were a couple of things that we
found in the das budget
one of them was the errata sheet we just
took care of
the other one was at cyber security
which they've been paying to the tune of
600 000
was supposed to been transferred over to
doit
because it hits every agency and every
branch so it's not just the executive
branch but also the judicial branch so
we've made those question that we've
made those changes
and we are working now to restore
admin services to where they would have
been if they'd made the same amount of
cuts as everybody else but not had to
cut so many people because of the
mistakes in the budget so nancy if you
will walk us through it please
sure madam chair the what you have in
front of you
are 20 pages thank you mike for
stringing these together because they
were 20 separate documents
and these restore the 20 positions
that the agency specified
as having been unfunded
in their budget it's you would find it
on the last page page 18
of the agency's
budget presentation
and this is just all the backup for
every one of those items
the only change that we made at the
agency's request from what you saw
was i believe um
it's the very first request their very
first prioritized need
which is a new position
it is not um it was included in their
request but it was not um unfunded it
was a new position for an administrator
to handle the five different attached
boards
that have been
put into the department's budget
and so you'll see that as priority
number one and the reason you're seeing
priorities here is because subsequent to
their presentation to the division
they did provide our office with a
ranking for each one of the bundles if
you recall they issued i believe it was
fixed bundled and they were a buy
um
category whether it was procurement
public works personnel
audit or the commissioner's office and
the budget office and subsequent to
their presentation
um
given that the um
the division was interested in the
positions they supplied priorities for
each position individually and so that's
why you see a priority number in order
for each position and the reference to
the bundle that they had originally
so a very long-winded way of saying
these are the 20 positions in priority
order and their impact on the budget
several of these
are shared i'm sorry have a mixed
funding source so there would be um as
you'll see an agency income piece so
that's not all general funds
um a several of them are part-time and
not full-time
so um they're amount to small salaries
and benefits
but the net um
for all of these
was described um
prior to this so
these represent the restoration of
essentially 20 unfunded positions except
for the one new one so 19 unfunded and
one new
if there are questions again i'm going
to let nancy
answer them represent walls
thank you so i've opened their bundles
and uh it was a total of about
approximately 1.3 million per year
and i'm losing this a little bit is this
600 000 through the biennium or 600 000
per year per year
so it's one
six and six twelve so it's most of what
their bundles were is what it sounds
like
it's everything
it's all of those positions that they
identified
everything
it's 600 000 per year and it was 1.3
million per year
that they showed on their bundles so it
sounds don't forget don't forget the 600
000 from cyber security that they also
were erroneously paid for so we had
their errata sheet
and then we had the other six hundred
thousand commissioner goulet is still
working on the details of that amendment
and i don't have it yet
so to be clear it looks like we are
restoring
almost everything that were in their six
bundles
am i correct
yes for positions only these were just
the positions
and the agency is as the chair indicated
um
going to be providing some language
for the
cyber security piece
and we are also working on a possible
house bill one amendment
to um
make these positions
um
well i'll leave it at that this is the
das piece that we're talking about right
here so
they're funding um
keith is all is being worked on
so that we can provide the backup for
these funds
thank you for helping me understand this
representative emerick uh moves the
approve
the approval of the adoption of the
administrative services
bundled priorities represent griffin
seconds
i don't see any additional
conversation
sir clerk if you are ready
madam chairman yes vice chairman the
clerk vote chance representative griffin
yes representative leitchman
representative hatch
bill
he probably left the room absent
represented waltz
yes
the vote is six to nothing unanimous
okay
um thank you very much oba thank you i
can't tell you nancy you and mike how
much i miss having you here with us i
try not to say that every day it sound
like i'm whining we are now going to be
in
lunch recess until 12 30 when we have
peas development authority
in lba we're going to turn off the sound
here i don't know what you're going to
do i think our equipment in this room
now does seem to
be strong enough that we can leave it up
with a just a lunch recess out
sign on
we'll put a sign up
going to be discussing
p's international
and i think
gino is
well he was with us
he is with us
hi gene no
you're you're muted
high unmuted representation you're not
muted now welcome thank you for coming
and talking to us well thank you for
having us uh for the record gino marconi
i'm the director of the peas development
authority division of ports and harbors
and with me is mr paul breen who is the
executive director of the pease
development authority
i tell you what this is your
presentation for people if anybody's
watching at home i don't see anybody so
just us your budget is on page 846 in
our governor budget book san gina we're
going to turn it over to you to talk to
us welcome thank you for coming
well i'm i'm going to defer for a second
so that uh paul can introduce himself
and okay
just
hi paul green peace development
authority executive director thank you
for having gino and i um
as most of you know pursuant to chapter
290 the new hampshire state court
authority was transferred to the pda
effective july 1st 2001.
you know paul you're going to have to
move closer to i apologize for the
equipment we are in
a room with extra
air cleaning equipment but it's a little
bit noisy okay i apologize i just wanted
to to remind everyone that uh effective
july 1st 2001
bees development authority um took over
the division of watson harbors and i'll
let i'll let director marconi go in
detail on on the budget for that
thank you
all right representative um
as paul said 2001 we were merged
administratively with ps
but the enabling statute required that
any
existing
classified employees positions remain
classified employee positions
so we currently have six full-time
classified positions one of which is not
has not been uh is empty
uh the person retired and
that was the operations manager
and uh we we did a rehire and we did it
as a peas employee
we have four
part-time
uh
year-round
classified employees
uh
again over the years through attrition
as uh our harbour masters
our part-time harbour masters were
leaving
uh we hired we hired harbor masters as
uh as pda employees
so what you see in front of you is is
basically the
the pay for those employees and and with
the full-time ones the benefits
but i think it's important uh to say
that
they're paid
their pay comes out of the classified
system and the check checks are cut cut
by the state
but we reimburse
the general fund for these payments for
these folks
payroll
so that
in the end there is no net effect on
general fund revenues
right
and soon i would imagine at some point
in the
future i don't know how far in the
future
everybody will be a peas employee and
not no longer a state employee right
well this is this there's one little
thing that we're trying to work through
and that is that two of those positions
by statute are required to be police
officers
certified by pstc
and they're in group two
um group two retirement
uh so we're trying to have some
discussions on
how that could work
with the legal authority that peace has
so we've got some discussions going on
with that
um
our chief harbour master has been with
us a long time
um and uh
i'll say i'll say about our deputy chief
harbour master that at the last
executive council meeting the governor
name nominated uh my deputy chief grant
nichols to be the uh
assistant director of uh emergency
management and homeland security under
over under d.o.s oh
yeah i i got to tell you something
he's perfect for the job he's been with
us for 15 years
um and uh and uh
high loss is there again but good for
grant he's he's a he's a great guy a
hard worker
does anybody have any questions these
guys have been doing a great job for us
they're entirely
self-funded and
it's just fun to see them once every
couple of years
well if you come down to the seacoast
representatives uh you know we can show
you around especially pick a sunny day
though
yeah i'll pick a sunny day and i'll tell
you most of us sitting in this room now
have been vaccinated so we are joining
herd and moving forward and trying to
help
stop this horrible disease yes
any questions representative burge
thank you madam chairman thank you for
your presentation this is probably
either a question for
the chairman or yourself
i don't know under well page 846
item zero two zero current expression
expenses how does one crystal ball
current expenses for two years in
advance
i mean i just it to me it
doesn't make sense
the words don't work and i well they're
stuck with whatever das gives them for a
a class line so
i don't know what gene's got in there i
mean we're talking about 220 dollars but
it's
they don't have any
choice over what those are called
that's our budget system
and and if i may madam chair the i mean
the the budget system
is classifieds
the scale is in is in the book and it's
a step system so right what they do is
this is again this is i'm not
a finance guy but what they do is they
look at the step system and they know
who's up for the next step and then they
have the
um increases that that are required
until our annual increases the cost of
living increases and so that's that's
how some of these numbers get uh
increased over over the period of time
yeah
so i don't see any questions on your
budget are we ready to approve the
budget
representative memrick moves approval of
the budget representative griffin
seconds
representative to burge when you're
ready please call the rule
okay madam chairman yes vice chairman
yes the clerk votes yes representative
griffin yes representative leishman
representative hatch
as absent representative walls
can't hear you i think she's muted but
she said yes okay got it i did say yes i
apologize
we're six to nothing gino thank you for
spending the time with us and keep up
the good work and
nice to see you thank you and enjoy the
rest of your day thank you
okay my friends i have yet another hb1
amendment
and
representative burge
reinforced his roll call sheet supply at
lunch
so there's oops nope it didn't fall on
the floor
um nancy and mike
this is the department of justice this
is their errata sheet
we really don't know anything about it
all she said was there was an errata
sheet if you can bring it up
on the screen so we can
see it and then somebody
tell us it looks like they are making
a couple of small changes
can you hear me this is mike oh we can
um can you see the uh department of
justice sheet in front of you and we can
and is it large enough
it's got a lot of roads
it looks like they moved
i don't know what they did with the
money they just moved some stuff out
well when they came in they uh talked
about an irs
um
problem that they identified
the uh the medical investigators as
employees where the state had been
treating them as contractors yeah
so the department of justice challenged
that
and the irs reversed their positions so
now the department of justice can treat
these
investigators as contractors
so they're moving the appropriations
from
class lines that would be
to pay
employees in for example 14 and then
further down you see quite a bit in
class 50
and the benefit lines and they're moving
that into the contracts for program
services line
there's no general fund impact it's just
a small adjustment at the bottom from
one source of funds to another less than
less than ten thousand dollars involved
in each line
any questions
representative emerick moves the
amendment
representative griffin's seconds
when you are ready
sir clerk we will take the role
madam chairman yes vice chairman
the clerk votes yes representative
griffin yes repetitive leishman
representative
hatch
i don't see him
uh representative walsh
are you muted again
representative waltz are you muted
yes i keep i'm sorry i try to do that to
be considerate and then i forget i've
done it
okay thank you
okay
um
i'm going to
put this away in one folder
shuffle around and
bring out some paperwork i got from lba
that
i think i'm hoping mike is going to be
able to tell us why we have this
we're going to go to
your hb2
book again and we're going to go to
section
which
let me tell you what page we're looking
at
page 55 which i think we had approved
this already so
this section so i'm not quite sure where
we have this
little bit of amendment but the
amendment mike is 2021-0687
h
tracy
okay we're looking at this section we
actually had approved and now we have a
little amendment so if you can
tell us what's going on with that mike i
greatly appreciate it
yes um
this was when the
department of labor was in
and
nancy pointed out that there was a
drafting error at the very end of
section 127 and that last sentence
was new
right so rather than having it lost in
the shuffle i asked legislative services
just to fix it now
so we wouldn't have to keep track of it
as a technical correction at the end of
the process
works for me
and we all approve this with that
language in it so
um i will move to approve amendment
202106 87h representative emmerich
seconds
any questions on this
see none if you could call the role
madam chairman yes vice chairman the
clerk votes yes representative griffin
remember the leashman
representative hatch i believe is not
back representative walsh yes the vote
is six nothing madam chairman it's
unanimous
okay let me see if i have anything else
that's
relatively easy to do here
i think i need four more pairs of hands
not two more pairs of hands i need
four more pairs of hands
my husband always maintains he just
needs to clone himself to get everything
done
maybe that would help
uh mike
is amendment
2021 0695
hb 281
i believe it is yes
okay let's
look at that because at least all of us
read hb 281 when it was the floor of the
house so although it's several pages
long here
we've had a bite at the apple already we
passed it last
house session
this is amendment 2021-06958
this is being added to
excuse me
hb2
at the request
of chairman
norman major and vice chairman patrick
abrami this bill passed on the floor of
the house so it is the house
position and this is exactly what you
saw
on the floor of the house
what it does
is on the
last page
um
it suspends the effective date
until january 2026
of the single sales factor
apportionment
and we were asked to put this into hb2
as a new section because of house
approved
buy the house
during our last session
so i would move the adoption of
amendment two zero two one o six nine
five h
representative emerick will second
discussion on the motion
i love it when you've had something two
or three weeks ago to read so now we're
not all fumbling with something we
haven't seen before
sir clerk if you could call the role i
see no discussion
okay thank you madam chairman yes
uh vice chairman yes the clerk votes yes
representative griffin yes represent
representative hatch is not back
representative walsh
yes the vote is six nothing madam
chairman is unanimous
thank you
i did not alleviate my need for four
more pairs of hands
oh my god
you're keeping up with me i'm i'm
drowning in paper over here
okay
we're still waiting for nancy on that
one
okay i want to go to section 53
in house bill 2
which is page 25.
oh and tracy is waiting for me not to
hog
and keep all these
but to pass them out
which would mean somebody else gets some
of my paper there's yours
there's mine
thank you
[Music]
this believe it or not is a relatively
easy
cut in the budget of a small amount but
since we have fewer revenue dollars
than we have other things we're looking
on page 25.
yesterday commissioner caswell talked
about wanting to hire
a new staff member
the director of intergovernmental
affairs
that position is currently empty
and this relates to the job
and what this amendment does
is it says yes you can hire that person
but it takes effect january 1
so it pushes
much of the expenditure out of this
biennium
into the last six months of the year and
hopefully by then everything will turn
around and we'll have more revenue on
the other hand
if
things turn around faster than ways and
means things this is an easy change for
the senate to make if they end up with a
lot more money than we have so i've left
everything the way it is said yeah you
can have this position but we're not
going to fund it until the last six
months of the biennium
representative emerick adopts amendment
2021-0738 and moves to adopt
0738h representative emerick
griffin seconds
it would be nice if
we ended up with a lot more money
but if we don't this is an easy cut
position isn't there anyway we'll just
save a few dollars
madam chair does nancy know how much
this might save us or
um
we don't need it now but i don't know
right now but we're gonna find out
i still am waiting for representative
wyler to tell us exactly how much our
portion of
the cuts we have to make are i did tell
him we would got more revenue back by
hiring some auditors he was pleased
okay see no discussion representative
to burst will you please call roll
madam chairman yes vice chairman yes the
clerk votes yes
representative griffin yes
leishman sorry representative hatch
is absent representative walls yes the
vote is six nothing madam chairman it's
unanimous
okay we're gonna have a brief
eight or nine minute recess we have the
liquor commission
oh no they're not coming till two
why are they not coming till two
that's a longer break than i wanted
um
mike do we have anything that we could
deal with
i have
one more
house bill one amendment drafted
that deals with a small business
development center
could you bring that over
sure
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
is it visible
yes it's visible
nope
we don't want to do that
okay i emailed you and nancy a change
earlier in the day
okay we have
you know what mike i think we adopted
the wrong amendment
which one
the bill that represents uh
281 and unfortunately i don't have a
copy of that in here and i'm using my
i'll talk to you about it later
i don't have anything else current that
we have seen
have we got anything in hb2
that i we were going to talk to you guys
about that we haven't
uh was
did anthony finish that amendment with
ken mayfield's change on the due process
um i haven't seen that yet from oh
actually i emailed you something
yesterday i believe but i was up here
yesterday
ken
uh marifield
his people were looking at
it
in more depth i guess that was anthony's
proposed change to his language
yeah i i did send you anthony's proposed
change but then later i heard from ken
merrifield
who asked if
he asked his hearing officer to look at
the language
and
i did hear from representative walsh
that she was interested in what ken
merrifield was going to provide
well until that amendment's ready to be
released it can't be released and i
guess anthony
held it up with ken's whole
permission
that could
be i do you can't release that right now
okay
um it can we go to page
and look at the dnc changes it's not
clear to me
which ones generate revenue
and which ones do not generate revenue
and the
commissioners spoke about this briefly
but then even when i read it later i
wasn't positive
i understood
her revenue issues
man and chair are you 62 in hb1 or hb2
i'm in hb2
now let me see if that's
it's section
142 six on page 62
which is at the bottom of the page
and the commissioner briefly discussed
this
and then later when i read it
mike can you run us through this i mean
it
it doesn't it looks like it's existing
language
and chair
these are
these are appropriations for essentially
park projects
that they're hoping to generate
additional revenue for
in campgrounds upgrading the uh the rv
um hookups right but where does it say
what the revenue is nancy
they did not supply i don't believe they
supplied any revenue associated with
with these items i'd have to go back and
look at
reason that explains why i couldn't find
it in here
yeah i mean i i remember her discussing
it um as being you know
particularly in hampton
um
at the hampton rv park that they could
fill those
rather quickly
and same at jericho mountain but
additional revenue i don't know if they
supplied anything to that effect
and as written this is a general fund
appropriation
right but she did tell us we were
getting revenue from it
i'd have to go back and look at their
presentation in more detail i don't
think it was in the presentation i had
the presentation at home and then i
tried to read this online
and i couldn't find it when i was
reading hb2 online when i was home
right and you know these are
essentially capital appropriations as
well but
okay what do we have in the in the
budget hb2 last year
for
fort stark because it seems to me this
has gone to 615 000
and i thought i remembered something
smaller that perhaps
the senate took out
yes um
in 2019 there was a house bill two
appropriation in the
the thrift which was the
number of one-time projects
and it was deleted during the process i
don't know exactly when
or i believe the amount was around 400
or 350 000 i'd have to double check that
but it did drop out during the process
yeah and we put it in in the house but i
think this is double what they asked for
i think you are right about that i can
um verify that
so if i can it
she said starting on line nine now i'm
on page sixty three
the sum of sixty six hundred fifty five
thousand for the purpose of
redevelopment improvement projects at
jericho mountain beach area campground
including the rv dump station two new
pit toilets ten campsites four camping
cabins extension water facilities etc
she said that section would bring in
revenue
yes
recall that she discussed that as
being a very popular area and that they
could
generate revenue with the addition of
those projects but we don't have a level
of detail for that
let's see if we can figure out
which one she does she didn't say
there'd be any revenue for fort stark
what about the hampton rv park is she
getting did she say additional revenue
there
uh i'm not sure about that because it's
essentially an upgrade of the system
so
i'm not sure what revenue could be
attributable to that
if the lights exist now it's just an
upgrade to the amperage
did she say
that
rvs were bypassing them because they
couldn't use the electricity
they are they are obsolete it's my
understanding
i don't know that that means they're
being bypassed
but
certainly they could charge additional
amounts if they were upgraded
can you find out for us
for each of these sections
if there is additional revenue and if
yes what they think it is going to be
and can you also ask her why fort stark
has gone up so much more than it was two
years ago
i know construction has
increased
but a 50 percent increase in
construction costs in two years seems to
be a little high
yeah i can certainly touch base with her
and i'm not sure if appropriate to
mention but i'm not certain that the
increased revenue is not going to be
within the park fund either and not
general funds no it'd be in the park
fund but if she's making more money for
the parks then she can afford to pay for
more
i'm not looking for general revenue now
she would spend that on the parks
but she's asking as i understand this
for general fund dollars to upgrade the
park so did i misread that
no these are
these are general fund appropriations
okay i didn't misread that
no you did not
well you'll find that out for us and
then we have
if i turn
the page page 64
the bottom of page 64.
we have a section section 145
that we haven't voted on
and we need to repeal this nancy can you
speak to this
section 145. no one's 146 i'm sorry
bottom of the page line 34.
or mike i don't know who wants to talk
to you this is the doj
um yeah
this is uh
it's a little bit odd drafting because
is the body worn cameras
146 is in the middle of another section
that relates to the body worn cameras
but 146
is a repeal
of a commission
and i believe
i always get tripped up because these
sections are out of order
i think these are standard
this is standard language going back to
line 13
when when
legislative services drafts
the commission you'll see on line 33
that they have a report due november 1st
2021 and then the commission effectively
is repealed on the same date or day
later
so that's
how they handle commissions
in statute
so that
um
they don't go on forever
then we could basically get rid of that
well if you do they they submit a report
but they technically remain on the books
a chaptered study that goes out of
existence because it's in chapter law
these are in statute these are statutory
commissions
and i believe this kind of language was
developed several years ago
to
clean up the books as it were so that
these kinds of commissions don't
continue on ad infinitum okay so we
could just approve this
section to clean up the commission
language yes
well
if you flip to page 65
section 148 makes an appropriation for
that commission
so you may want to look at all the
sections together
what section is that
uh 148 on page 65.
so it's a five hundred thousand dollar
appropriation
nobody out of order
it's no wonder people can't read hb2
so they effectively go out of commission
literally
in 2021 and then they get an
appropriation
well that appropriation
isn't that to a different commission
no
no 105 d3a
no kidding
ah well 146 doesn't name the commission
and then you turn the page and now
a commission is named
why don't we gift these to division two
we can do that
so
mike and nancy
we're going to take these off our plate
by gifting
section
146 to division
two game 148
and we're going to give them 148
to division 2.
and that brings us to page 65 section
i'm sorry madam chair did you want to
keep 147.
i'd already gifted that away nancy okay
okay
[Music]
sorry yes i did no when mike came up
here i get i gifted away
and 149
because they're clearly
in safety
and i've gifted him a couple of a gift
division to a couple of more
this is an interesting way for division
one to to balance their budget we just
give things away
yeah 146 goes to them
so we're gifting them
145 146 147 148
and that brings us to 150
which is the office of the chief medical
examiner i believe that's in
um the ag isn't it
yes
and
jane tried to speak to these yesterday
can we look at section 150 and see
can you guys walk us through that please
i can't gift that one away i'm gonna
have to keep it
we received uh
or i received an email
corr um making some
restatements of
what they had for house bill 2 paperwork
when they came into the division yep and
it's much clearer and they're asking to
delete some unnecessary sections
so by any chance print that out and
bring us five or six copies so we have
some for the
clerk
i'll be happy to
all right maybe we can deal with that
nancy is
um do you do judicial counsel or does
mike
uh mike does but i do
all right well you're going to come over
here so i'm trying to find something
nancy can talk to us about while you're
on your way so we can
no i don't want to deal that now
okay mike that's all we've got you're
gonna have to bring that to us and then
we'll talk about judicial counsel and
the paperwork you've got so we will take
a
i don't know ten minute
break to give mike a chance to walk over
here so we're going to be muted for 10
minutes back in 10 minutes
approximately it is 1
10.
wait for mike to walk back
and then he's going to bring up some
stuff and walk us through it we have
copies but we haven't looked at either
so while we wait let's go to page 28 i'm
sorry 26 and hb2
section 58 which is one of ours
that we need to deal with
and section 58 which is on page 26 as i
said
has a one-line change
and what it does is the existing law
says any of which equipment purchase in
excess of five thousand dollars they
want to scratch five thousand dollars
and they want to replace that with the
approval threshold for contracts set by
the governor and council manual of
procedures and i believe they changed
that a few years ago to ten thousand
dollars and so they're trying to bring
this up i don't see any problem with
approving this section so that it
matches what's in the manual does it
representative emerick moves to approve
section 58 represent griffin's second
set
is there any discussion on the motion
represent walls
thank you madam chair um it looks like
my first reaction is we should make this
permanent so we don't have to do this
annually and it looks like it is that
it's amending the rsa and that's right
correctly so this is permanent yes
all right
sir clerk when you're ready on the
motion to approve section 58.
i need a motion
representative emrick made the motion
represent griffin
seconded
okay
madam chairman yes vice chairman yes the
clerk votes yes
representative griffin representative
leishman yes representative hatch is
still excused represent waltz yes okay
madam six nothing
thank you
nancy while we're waiting for mike to
get back i want to go down to section
59.
section 59 extends a date the
appropriation shall not match so june
30th 2023. it's my understanding you dug
into that and there's only two hundred
thousand dollars of the six million
not expended is that correct
she may still be on the break or on the
phone
all right we will hold that question
nope ma'am i'm sorry i was muted myself
i apologize
no problem
um
it's not nothing like talking to the
wall uh you are correct i did not dig
into that but we did receive uh emailed
information from the department this
morning that the unobligated balance is
less than 200 000
so my original thought had been if it
was closer over a million or something
we would cut it because we had to make
some cuts since it's only down to less
than two hundred thousand dollars i
frankly think we should just to prove it
move this on does anybody have any other
thoughts
representative emmerich moves to approve
section 59 representative griffin
seconds
any discussion on the
motion see none
when the clerk is ready he will call the
roll okay madam chairman yes
uh vice chairman yes the clerk votes yes
representative griffin yes
representative leishman yes
hatch is still excused representative
walsh yes the vote is six nothing it's
unanimous madam chairman thank you we
are going to turn the page
the top of the next page in hb2 we're
now on page 27
we're looking at
section 60.
this is a section that is existing from
i think word for word from last year's
hb2
changing the date to the new biennium
so this is chapter law not in rsa but
changing it to june 30th 2023
is there a motion to approve
representative emmerich moves to approve
section
60 representative griffin's seconds
is there any discussion on the motion
scene none will the clerk call the rule
madam chairman yes vice chairman yes the
clerk votes yes
representative griffin
representative leishman yes
representative hatch is still the excuse
uh represent waltz
yes the vote is six nothing ma'am
chairman the it's unanimous
thank you
mike has mike gotten back yet
from his sprint across over to
us
yes i took the subway from the lob to
the state house
way to go all right if you can bring up
what we just got from doj and we're
going to be looking at page
65 basically
um section
150 on line 31 and mike's going to bring
up a document
that they have just printed
and grade and scat and
scratch through what they don't want and
he's going to walk us
through these
so i'm on page three of the letter
and at the bottom of that page you'll
see the statement that the language
strikeouts on the attached document are
requested to remove from house
be removed from house bill 2 is
introduced
and the request is to keep
the remaining text for the
medical examiner and director of
diversity outreach
positions and as i understand this this
would uh
go along with that house bill 1
amendment to um
restore the previous
language regarding the medical examiners
because
since the irs is no longer pursuing this
they can pay them as contractors
and this email was copied to the
the budget director was included so um
i didn't hear any resistance from from
that office
so this basically
goes along with that house bill 1
cleanup
so if we
move on to
page i don't know if these pages are
numbered but 65 of house bill 2
they're asking to strike
section 151
which would have authorized an
unclassified position
so since they are
paying
these people as contractors they don't
need to establish that position
and as we scroll down to 154
that looks like language that would have
paid a dollar amount
for certain investigations which would
be consistent with a paid contractor
and then submitting claims
so uh
an unclassified position would have been
on salary and wouldn't have
gone through that process
155 is being eliminated that would have
established a deputy chief
uh
it's plural so more than one definite
deputy chief forensic investigator
156.
not
sure exactly what they're doing there
i'm not either but if they don't want it
it's about cremation of human remains so
they're in charge of that
and they were making some changes to the
law that i guess they've decided they
don't need
correct
so basically mike if i have this from
their document that we just all just got
and we've been looking at with you
yes you could make a an amendment
hopefully one not four but to delete
section
155 and 156
and that is
exactly what i asked ols for
okay
so that means
we could approve sections 150
152 and 153
all dealing with
the chief medical examiner
and i guess i'd hang on to the other two
for a minute because if we get
real crunch time trying to cut
positions the easy thing is to push
those out rather than cut them so they
don't hire them right away to save a few
bucks
so
let's could i have a motion to approve
section
section 152 and section 153
for the office of the chief medical
examiner
representative emerick moves to approve
section 150 152 and 153 represent
griffin seconds that is there any
discussion on the
motion the motion should just be yes
it's a motion to approve sections 150
152 and 153
yep you're welcome
no we we bundled him we bundled okay
um
okay for the roll call madam chairman
yes vice chairman yes the clerk votes
yes representative leishman yes i'm
sorry representative griffin sorry
representative hatch is absent excuse of
represent walls yes
the emotion is six nothing uh unanimous
madam chairman
thank you
all right let
they me that all in one section i'm just
going to mark it off and then we will
have an amendment
to delete those other sections when we
get done okay cool
all right
so
let me talk to you about
the small business development center
and i don't right now have
an amendment for that
i think each of us has been flooded with
emails
saying that they were cut
eight hundred and four and eighty
thousand dollars over the course of a
biennium and they couldn't exist without
that
so what the governor had originally done
was put fifty thousand
[Music]
into
next year and zero the year after
i'm not sure where the figure that we've
been getting in our emails came from
well the cuts of 440 000
in each of the two years
if you look at the budget
they were they max they have been
authorized in the budget is 315 000.
which is
a hundred and twenty five thousand less
than what we're being told
was in the budget
i talked to the governor's budget
director this morning
and i told him we were going to transfer
money out of the
rooms and meals tourism line
and we were going to fund
small business development center
at 225
in the first year and 225 000 in the
second year representative leishman you
found that what was the amount of money
they actually spent
in 2020
in 2020 madam chair was 166
000 and change so in 2020 the small
business development center spent
166 000
of state funding
we don't know exactly what they will
spend
in 21 because that year is ongoing
but we're proposing i'm going to propose
an amendment to give them
225 000
in each of two years
it's not quite as much as they got in
the last biennium
but you we've seen state agency after
state agency come in and say
my spending level in general funds is
down twelve percent or five percent or
four percent depending on the size of
their unit so i do think we all wanted
to give them money and we wanted to give
them reasonable money to go forward and
this is going to require some belt
tightening but the state's doing some
belt tightening and hopefully we'll have
that amendment the next time we meet
it seemed like
a compromise
and responds to the emails we got
nancy is that you with your hand up
it is me madam chair with my hand up and
um
i wish it said nancy and
lavenas figure that out by the time we
meet again actually i sign on with mike
hoffman's
name so it'd be confusing if they're
like
you you guys share a license don't you
we do
yeah that's that's it so that's why and
and um so this is a little less than i
originally thought but when i found out
how much money they really were budgeted
as opposed to what we were sent
that's what i think we'll do there's a
little bit of confusion because they did
receive an appropriation late
in the budget process last
session um in-house bill 2 of 125 000 in
each fiscal year
well maybe by the time we get done the
senate they can raise that right so
that's that's why that you see that 100
number floating around well i want to
give them something i wanted to keep
going i think we all do and i think
we're cognizant of how much money we're
having to cut
so that's
what i think we can do for them
all right i think now we're still
i don't have anything else
lba do you have anything that we should
have discussed that we haven't
for the agencies i mean we've still got
some agencies that are coming in we have
the national guard coming in
we're going to have liquor at two
o'clock the public hearing by the way i
think you all got to notice
is next tuesday starting at one o'clock
it's zoom
i think that division one will meet
tuesday morning i told ken
that then what i'm going to do is drive
home and zoom from the house because i
think that could go on quite a while and
i'm not going to stay up here in room
202 at least at home if i need a snack i
can run down and get a snack
watch my cats try to upset my monitor
whatever is going on
okay we're going to be then if nobody
has anything nancy your hand is still up
or
up again
no it is not up again it will be down
momentarily okay
just wanted to be sure
um we will be in recess until two
o'clock when the liquor commission is
joining us
we will be back
the time being two o'clock i'd like to
call the division back to order
we are
going to be working with the liquor
commission on their budget
i thought we were going to have a person
or two from the liquor commission in
person
i know we have the commissioner but he's
muted
there he is hi joe
adam chair how are you today
we're good thank you for joining us
my pleasure
okay so we're here to
talk about your budget i know i sent you
a few questions but you know as always
those questions aren't
the extent of what we're going to do
so i'd like to turn it over to you to
start your
presentation absolutely
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee
my name is joseph malik i'm the chairman
of the new hampshire liquor commission
uh with me is our cfo tina demirs
our coo rose wyatt
mark armagenian our director of
enforcement and education and jessica ko
our it lead
just a quick thank you for the
opportunity to provide you an overview
of the liquor commission's fy 2223
operating budget
and just
to let you know that the commission is
very mindful of our statutory
responsibility to optimize revenue for
the state of new hampshire
while at the same time maintaining
controls and improving efficiencies of
our business
we feel that the 2223 budget supports
the level of funding that will allow us
to maintain safe operations
while returning maximum revenue to the
general fund
just quickly
the two areas of the budget that i would
like to bring to your attention is the
first is staffing
the funds associated with our positions
is 56 percent of our budget
and even at this level the commission
operates with a very
very lean full-time labor force and what
i would consider a robust part-time
labor force
the second is the funding necessary to
implement and maintain
the new next gen d6 365
software platform to support our new
point of sale and back office financial
systems that are currently scheduled to
go live at the end of this year
and at this point madam chair i would
turn the presentation over to our cfo
tina demirs and have tina walk you
through our presentation thank you very
much
good afternoon madam chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
tina demers i'm the cfo for the liquor
commission
i'll be taking you through the today's
presentation
on page two is an introduction
we first want to remind everyone that
the liquor commission is self-funded our
budget is in a separate liquor fund lisa
spend a moment
mary beth
can you hear her
i can but i i don't have the documents
that's what i was just trying to figure
out but but yes i can hear her thank you
i think they're bringing it up on the
lba website
i that's what i've been refreshing thank
you
tina
be sure the microphone is really close
to you
we have great air filtering
equipment in our rooms it exchanges all
the air five times an hour
takes out all those nasty covered
particles and everything else but it's a
wee tiny bit noisy
okay
thank you so i will speak up
is that better
yes
okay
uh
so the liquor fund is self-funded
our budget is a separate liquor fund
outside of the general fund and no
general fund appropriations are used to
maintain our operations
the commission operates 69 retail
outlets nine state owned and 60 leased
they generated over 617 million in net
retail sales in fy 20.
product is shipped out of two warehouses
one is state owned and the other is
contracted with dhl
liquor revenue is transferred to the
general fund after deducting
administrative costs and our transfers
to the alcohol abuse prevention and
treatment fund and the granted advantage
health care trust fund
beer tax and permit revenue is
transferred in a separate line item to
the general fund
and the budget
presented is the level of funding
necessary to support our revenue
estimates and our mission to optimize
revenue for the state of new hampshire
on page three we've provided the revenue
trend and the transfer language there
are two laws that govern liquor fund
transfers the first is the five percent
of previous year gross profit
transferred to the alcohol abuse
prevention and treatment fund and the
second is the additional funds in the
event of a shortfall in the granite
advantage healthcare trust fund
on line one net revenue for fy 20 is a
little over
141.8 million and increases to a little
over 149 million in fy 23.
line 2 is the 5 transfer to hhs that
starts at a little over 10 million in fy
20 and increases to just under 11
million in fy 23.
on line three is the transfer to the
general fund for fy 20 it was
131.8 million
the amount for fy21 is the amount that
would have been transferred to the
general fund if not for the additional
funds requested by hhs and our fy 22 and
23 are a little over 138 million
on line 4 we've provided the revenue
plan numbers
with line 5 showing the difference
based on current trends the estimated
transfer to the general fund for fy 22
and 23 is 1.6 million and 2.1 million
higher than the estimates currently in
hb1
on line six is the additional 8.5
million that's already been transferred
to hhs this year for the shortfall in
the granite advantage
so this leaves a transfer to the general
fund this year of approximately
128.5 million
line eight is beer tax which remains
around 13 million and line nine is the
total of the transfer to the general
fund
it's also important to note that our
expenses to net sale ratio is consistent
at 10 percent
online i mean on page four
we list out our major but we have a
question yeah okay yeah thank you i'm
sorry to interrupt you but i have a
question regarding your alcohol abuse
and prevention program uh do you have
any data to su to support that it's been
positive that it has a a good you know
impact they just transfer the money they
don't collect the data that's a
different crew that's a different group
okay sorry thank you
so you're off the hook you guys can send
me a candy bar for that
thank you
what what kind do you like
on page four we're listing our major
budget categories that correspond to the
numbers on page five to the spreadsheet
on page five
so item number one are salaries and
benefits they're decreasing in fy 22 as
a result of position changes and a
decrease in the retiree health
fy 23 increase
are to fund the 27th pay period in other
increments
current expense includes 2.8 million for
our advertising contract and other items
such as office and cleaning supplies
paper bags and receipt rolls for our
outlet stores
rents and leases this is to fund the
necessary current rent obligations and
expanding square footage for new outlet
locations
fy21 budget is underfunded because of
outlet changes that we've made after the
budget period so this creates a larger
increase in fy 22. fy 23 is level funded
utilities
in fy 22
are decreasing and are flat funded in fy
23 as a result of more energy efficient
outlets
item number five contracts for operation
includes our maintenance contracts such
as electrical hvac
security systems
and smart safes and armored car services
which we added in november of 2018.
fy 22 funding is based on current
contracts and our projected needs
fy 23 increase is a result of an extra
million dollars for maintenance and
support contract for the d365 software
platform this is to support the point of
sale and back office financial system
doit is the funding needed to maintain
our current pos and back office systems
and additional funds necessary for
licensing cloud services and other
annual software requirements to support
the new d365 software platform
equipment includes items such as
shelving checkouts on this item number
seven is checkouts and security cameras
for new and updated outlets and a
rotation plan for replacing
existing equipment such as vehicles
floor cleaners and forklifts
number eight in-state travel this is the
funding for
store moves and staffing changes
and number nine
other expenses the primary change is
from debt services
which is based on the current bond
schedule and estimates for new debt
i'd also like to note that you'll see
changes in the indirect cost line
because the total for the agency was
previously budgeted and paid for out of
accounting unit 1023 financial
administration and in fy 22 and 23 we've
reallocated the amount to the divisions
as listed
we'll go to page six the fy 22 requested
budget is 1.1 million or 1.4 percent
more than the fy 21 adjusted authorized
budget
a number of class categories decreased
such as salaries and benefits utilities
equipment and debt and a number of class
categories increased such as rents
contracts and doit
this is a result of fy21 adjusted
authorized budget versus what we
actually spent
so with fy22 based on what our current
spend pattern is
there are two pie charts
show the annual budget
first by class with salaries and
benefits making up 56
and then the other one by accounting
unit to show that store operations makes
up more than 75 percent of our budget
on page seven
fy 23 budget the requested budget is 3.4
million or 4.3 percent increase over
fy22
the two main reasons for the budget
increase is the 2.1 million in salaries
and benefits for the 27th
paycheck and a million dollars in
contracts and operations for the d365
maintenance of support contract
but we've also included an appendix for
a technical correction requesting to
move the funds for the contract from
class 103 to class 38 software
technology which i will explain when we
get further on into that page
tina can you stop a minute
we're seeing agency after agency come in
and and be
lower percentage than last year
so seeing
a 4.3 percent increase here
and in a previous one you also had an
increase
i
i'm concerned
that other agencies are making some cuts
and i appreciate you guys raise money
but we need
i currently need to cut
quite a bit of money i mean you must
know what the ways and means revenue
estimates were
so i'm concerned about all of these
increases
well the increase for fy 23 you'll see
the 2 million of that is for the
salaries and benefits for the 27th pay
period and we have no control over that
and well i did get that out and i don't
think yours was that much lba did give
me a share on that i will double check
that when i go home but i don't think
yours was that high on what they
expected it to be
our our average checks right now for a
pay period is about 1.5 million
and we are looking at increasing our
revenue estimates for 22 and 23 by the
1.6 and the 2 million
i would just say madam chair is you know
to have this type of revenue increase
where our revenue uh versus prior year
our net profit
is up 14.7
or
13.9 million and our actual uh
revenue to the general fund is up 5.2
percent or 4.4 million at this point i
think it would be uh i think it would be
a miscalculation of our funds to be able
to cut anything now and continue to
drive those profits when we're when
we're finally after many years coming
into our own and expanding our brand
i think the numbers speak for themselves
if you were in the room you would hear
the sighs i'm hearing joe
i hear what you're saying but i am
concerned
please continue
thank you madam chair
so on page seven the pie charts show the
same breakdown by class and accounting
unit
on page eight
the commission is the organizational
structure and the commission is made up
of three divisions that report to the
chairman and the deputy commissioner
blow are the divisions with the areas of
responsibilities listed and the number
of unclassified and classified positions
assigned to each
how many positions are unfunded in each
of these divisions
we have no unfunded positions how many
positions are vacant in each of these
divisions
at this point we have about 24 vacant
positions
in which division
mainly in store operations
would you like the breakdown
what would you like me to no
please continue
on page nine
provides a breakdown of the office of
the commission and followed by each
division
the primary budget changes are the same
throughout fy 22
result of reallocating of indirect costs
and fy 23 is for the 27th pay period so
at this point i won't take the time to
go through each individually unless you
would like me to madam chair
what does the division
guys what would you like her to do
okay please continue
okay so you'll see for the office of the
commission the fy 22 budget increase is
or 545 000 but the indirect cost that
was reallocated to this division was 527
000 so there really isn't much of an
increase in 22 and the fy 23 budget is
increasing 2
or 31 000 for that extra paycheck
and all of that
tina some of those uh reallocations came
out of your division right
your office
came out we will see we will see a
corresponding
lowering
in your area
correct about 1.8 million in in finance
administration okay thank you you're
welcome
uh
so each page we provided a pie chart
that shows um the office of the
commission salaries and benefits
and then the breakdown for operating
the
authorized full-time positions in this
division is two unclassified and two
classified positions
on page 10 we have the division of
enforcement and i also highlighted on
each page the corresponding um pages in
the house bill 1
so you know where each division starts
yeah that's very helpful thank you
you're welcome
uh fy 22 budget is increasing 1 or 36
000 for enforcement
but they also have the added 32 000 for
indirect costs so enforcement is pretty
much flat funded in fy 22 and fy 23
budget is a 5 increase or 232 000 and
that's to fund the additional pay
paycheck
can you talk about the position changes
under salary you have a 82 000 decrease
what positions changed
um
we had some people that retired and you
have new people coming on at a lower um
step
and we also had some positions that we
dragged
for a period of time
okay thank you
in the division of enforcement the
authorized full-time positions one
unclassified 12 sworn in 12 civilian
i mean 21 sworn i'm sorry and 12
civilian
the division of enforcement provides
over
services for over 5 700 licensees
and they collect over 18 million in
revenue in fy 20.
on the next slide you have the division
of administration
fy 22 budget decrease 11 or a million
dollars there's the 1.8 million for the
deduction in indirect costs an fy 22
budget increase is 1.4
or 114 000 which is for the 27th pay
period
as you can see uh the doit budget makes
up about 60 of this division funding
the authorized full-time positions is
one classified
15 in finance seven in hr four in our
outlet auditors two inventory control
and three in legal
on page 12 we have the division of
marketing and merchandising
fy 22 budget increase is 2.5 or 1.6
million
this is because this division absorbed
most of the indirect cost of 1.3 million
fy 23 budget increase of 4.8 percent or
3 million dollars is for the 27th
paycheck and for the additional funding
for the maintenance and support contract
the authorized full-time positions is
one unclassified 13 in marketing and
merchandising 258 in the outlet store
operations and two in the warehouse
on page 13 i provided the workers comp
in unemployment comp budgets accounting
units
and then on page 14 we have the appendix
technical correction where we're
requesting to move the funding from
accounting unit
1030 store operations the class 103 to
class 38
on page 15 we provided you a snapshot of
the contract cover page where it was
approved through gnc
with the funding in class 38
so that concludes the presentation we've
also provided responses to madam chairs
questions so at this point we would be
happy to answer any questions that the
committee has
representative leishman
thank you madam chair
thanks for taking my question so i i
have a couple um on page
could you tell me why your overtime line
that's uh
accounting unit 18 at the bottom of the
page
in 2020 there was 17 000 and you're
forecasting 70 000 for this coming
biennium for the first year
i'm sorry what page you're on uh 343
madam chair it's under enforcement
it's uh right down the bottom of yep
that's for the um synar grant
and in the budget for
20 and 21 we had
less funding we only had
what was it one grant for sinar and
they've increased it by another
50 000
which was
so the the grant itself the funding for
the grant has increased
which was allocated throughout the the
um grant so you can see it went from
on page 344 for the total for fy22 it
was 50 000. in fy 22 and 23. it's 205.
okay how does that get increased why
how does that get increased
yeah so how does that get increased the
grant
we received additional funds from hhs so
there was a new uh grant award it went
through gnc
it started out at at 50 there was an
increase to 55 000 and then we just
received another 100 000.
okay so if i go to page 347
and i look at the
total
for
enforcement the fda tobacco i continue
that all the way down to again to the
total
are you saying that grant is responsible
for over a 60 increase in your expenses
because if you look at the actual of 142
and what you're planning for in
it's like 64 percent of my rough head
numbers
so that's because of the grant you're
saying
yes
interesting
i have i have nothing further at the
moment madam chair
other questions from committee members
phantom chair uh neither purpose or
balls
neither bill nor i have these documents
lba doesn't have them um they said
they're trying to get them from janet
nothing has turned up through this
entire presentation neither of us have
been able to follow this because we
don't have the documents and i just
wanted to point that out that we don't
really know what's going on
we are
i mean as as i said this morning one of
the things we've learned in this
division was why remote meetings are not
working well and here we are so thank
you for that well i think it might have
to do with when the liquor commission if
the liquor commission sent the documents
because nobody else seems to have them
except you guys and well we didn't get
them until later this afternoon when
they were brought in so we didn't have
them early either as you recall sitting
on the division last year most of these
documents are handed to you as they walk
through the door
which we appreciate so i i hear what
you're saying
um there's nothing i can do about it
sitting right now
nina can you tell me what
sinar actually is i guess i don't
understand
why you get a grant from hhs
i will defer that to the chief that
would be great because somehow
i think of you as selling product making
money spending
money to sell the product but making
money and giving it to us and us not
giving it back to you so this was a
little confusing
for me
and maybe mark can step up to the mic or
he has a mic back there he can explain
this to me
can you hear me
can you guys hear
me
not really
okay i'll come up
remember we have this air filtration
system
we have wonderful air
with a little bit of noise
uh first of all good afternoon uh and
thank you madam chair uh for those of
you who haven't met me yet my name is
mark armagenia and i'm the division
director for enforcement licensing um
the sinar grant that extra hundred
thousand dollars was actually awarded to
us through hhs to do alcohol compliance
it actually was facilitated through hhs
but came from the governor's commission
on drug and other drug i'm sorry alcohol
and other drug misuse
that money was utilized or is being
utilized uh in partnership with the
municipalities throughout the state
to do alcohol compliance
um at any one of our
uh
i think we're at 3 000 3400
retail licensees
so let me see if i have this
you sell product you make money
five percent of that money goes to the
governor's commission on alcohol abuse
and you got a hundred thousand dollars
of that back to work on compliance
so the money that was actually given to
us was actually not requested it was
actually
requested of us to run this program
so
um i i don't understand the five percent
turnaround
but
um
this was something that back in the day
was it was called util the util grant
uh for underage compliance
and it has just come forward in a
different entity
mark can you tell us how enforcement is
really organized do all of those people
report to you
uh yes we we have a rank structure for
uh and and that actually
is a rank structure that has been
minimized and leaned down
uh over the years but our
uh
our
enforcement personnel our
investigators actually report to a
supervisor a a boot on the ground
supervisor
so you have one supervisor
we have three supervisors for three
different teams
of
investigators throughout the state
okay are those supervisors part of the
21 sworn staff
yes
and how many do each of the three
supervisors have reporting to them
um
in the area of six to seven depending on
temporary assignments
where we need of course everything is
done driven here so if we see that data
is showing us that we need help in a
certain area we will actually
move that supervisor i'm sorry that
investigator to the particular area to
help out
so according to the information on page
8 you have 34
people in your enforcement
division and you of course are the one
unclassified under you you have three
33 classified of those three are
supervisors
having six to seven people reporting to
them so between 18 and 21 people
reporting to them
do the rest of the people report to you
uh no so
then um
on our administrative side of the house
which is
uh for the majority civilian staffing
we have
a civilian a civilian supervisor that
oversees the auditing area we have a
sworn supervisor that actually looks
over the
licensing area
and that is all overseen by a
lieutenant
so you have
a total of five supervisors
in your area
and they report to you
so the breakdown madam chair would be
uh three sergeants
uh two lieutenants
and then of course myself and the deputy
chief
and then
the rest our civilian
staff
can you get a
an org chart over here of your
staff for us
absolutely
thank you
um representative should i hear you had
a question
yes madam chairman you know thank you
for your presentation i'm still confused
with the grant that you received from
majesty i had asked earlier if you've
got any data just to prove that it's
been a positive
impact or effect and they got them off
the hook and now you're back yeah well
yeah but
so somebody's somebody's got an answer i
don't know
who's responsible for that
so
as it in regards to that grant we can
definitely provide that information
can you just give it to us now verbally
i i don't have that information on me
madam chair at the same time
uh not using it as an excuse but that
all the compliance checks are done with
underage buyers
and there has been a substantial amount
of time that we have not put the
underage buyers in the vehicles with our
investigators due to the health crisis
that is currently
going on
madam chair
yes mr hatch
i'm sorry i i wasn't sure you could see
my hand up or not i um no i was looking
at the piece of paper that represented
was just asking about to see if i saw
something that would help him what is
your question represent
well well thank you just um i'm on the
governor's commission also and
did this grant a increased personnel to
accomplish the end and b how much is
devoted to educational
factors for the stores
in terms of compliance and otherwise
thank you for your question
representative um first and foremost um
this grant
was a compliance grant
it's physically going out to our license
establishments our on-premise and
off-premise establishments
and with an underage buyer and doing in
and checking on compliance
may i continue madam chair follow-up
yes follow-up so i understand that i
understand that completely but is there
what efforts are given in that was part
of the discussion that was quite a while
ago in the commission in terms of
education
educating proprietors
and their personnel as to the
appropriate steps to take and what needs
to be be done in terms of compliance
there was a i'm just asking that because
there was a huge problem with that in
the past before your tenure of course
but nevertheless there it's been a huge
problem and
thank you for your question and and
ironically this was a conversation that
myself and then chairman had as i walked
in the door here four years ago and that
was about education our education our
training unit is extremely robust there
are two training uh coordinated uh neck
coordinators two training specialists
that are actually attached to that unit
um we give training not only
uh to
uh management
our management uh training seminars our
mts program so everybody who gets a
license that
person in charge that management has to
go through that
training to actually learn the negative
of
the negative outcomes to underage
service over service
and the liabilities that are incurred
through that we have a similar training
uh in our what we call our training
employee
seminar which is our team's program that
actually trains servers in the same
liabilities to include
detecting fictitious ids
the outward signs of intoxication
all all the tools that they would need
to be able to uh alleviate that
establishment and themselves from
liability or what liability would incur
with the business
we also teach a very similar seminar to
our own employees at our at our liquor
store outlets
we
have the
dre program
which is our drug recognition program
that we coordinate for the whole state
that's through a highway safety grant
we have
approximately 15 training seminars that
are actually out of that unit to to help
not only
our licensees
but
administrative personnel at schools
to to recognize the outward signs of of
uh intoxication and what to do in those
circumstances and who to call
thank you and thank you madam chair and
thank you for your questions you asked
most of mine
any other questions representative
leishman
thank you madam chair
so we heard from the
commissioner the department of
administrative services that has shown
us and seen documentation a lot of our
health care and benefits costs have been
reduced substantially
yet i'm looking at yours and i'm just
going i'll take a page here 349
and
compared to 2020 and going over to
2022 your benefits are up nearly 20
percent
so why are your costs for benefits
going up so much when other departments
and commissions and so forth in the
state
going down or staying flat
well the actual
budget for benefits is based on the
full-time positions or the benefits
associated
with um part-timers so that's that's
driven by the system it's not calculated
by us
so it could be that we've had a position
that changed from somebody that came in
with a family that before was on a
single plan
yeah
tina have you been having quite a bit of
turnover
um uh
in finance or agency well anywhere
because you're right as people change i
mean it's not as
you may have had some people who had a
baby who used to be a two person and so
now their family but i just wondered if
you were having from
retirements because we are have had a
lot of retirements
i mean some of that leads to turnover
yes we have had turnover
and that leads to benefit changes based
on
who you hire
correct
any other questions
going once going twice unsure if it may
yes i didn't know if your hand was up
again or hadn't gone down representative
hatch so absolutely you may
thank you very much volunteer just just
a side note i went into the newly
renovated uh gorham store last night and
a job well done looks good and hopefully
business gets back there
no samples though but anyways look great
you very much representative okay so if
we're going to do side notes
commissioner
representative hatch would like you to
get a liquor store up by is it the
shelburne
rest area bill that i hear about a lot
is that was that what the one you wanted
to worry what you wanted to put a liquor
store well no i was just worried about
the one in gorham that's but uh okay all
right i'll take two any day
thank you
all right looks like we're done thank
you very much for for coming you're
going to get a
you're going to get some stats over for
representative taberge and you're going
to get a
org chart for enforcement
over to us and i think those are the
only two questions we ask representative
emery i've forgotten something no no man
i'm sure i just had i had a question
about the upgrade of the hampton liquor
stores
to be more like what's on 93 is that
still scheduled
it is representative those uh we have uh
contracted with a real estate agent on
the seacoast and they are going through
the process of marketing those
properties for the liquor commission
as we speak
okay thank you
you're welcome
madam chair if i can uh those our our
program was dropped off at nine o'clock
this morning over at the state house so
i sincerely apologize for
uh they're not getting to uh the
representatives as commissioner we have
a couple of people who who are i mean
five of us are here in the state house
by nine o'clock this morning i was
meeting with the governor on something
else so you know it's just been one of
those days where we've all been running
here and there and we understand
now
there are really significant
difficulties with remote situations and
i think we have encountered almost all
of them including a sound board that was
losing a channel so we had constant
static and we tried
all kinds of things here we were the
most creative people at trying to get
rid of static so that represent walls of
representative hatch no longer had it in
their ear that you could imagine but
replacing the board finally is what did
it so you know it's been
up and down and we appreciate it we're
working the best we can through this
right now most of us here in this room
have been
happily vaccinated and
tracy took the hard way he had coveted
and recovered so he joined the herd the
hard way i took the vaccinated route
yeah we've just tried a variety of
things here and we're working together
it's not a perfect world even when you
sit in the same room but thank you for
saying that
have a great day thank you for coming
thank you for presenting i wish we'd
been able to see you in person but maybe
soon
thank you
chair thank you very much members of the
committee thank you thank you
okay guys we are adjourned until
tomorrow morning at nine o'clock
thank you for your hard work we made
quite a bit of progress today
i'm really seeing
i know they cut us off they took it out
of that room
you're still muted
by the way violet has a torn rotator
cuff but it could be you said that
yes